m
[Musique]
la rivière tout boy cheo
au delà du cours moyen
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du tchoum la tente
traditionnelle et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce jeudi 27 février coronavirus
l'épidémie est entrée dans une phase
décisive selon l'om est si le coc vide
19 semble avoir atteint un pic en chine
il continue de se propager notamment en
europe
edouard philippe considère qu'il n'ya
lieu ni d'avoir peur ni d'être
négligents face au risque d'épidémie en
france en italie manuel micron qui
insiste sur la coopération européenne
très étroite à cette crise de santé
publique
le président français est à naples pour
un sommet prévu de longue date une
rencontre avec le premier ministre
destinée à relancer les échanges entre
les deux pays
le nouveau affrontements eu lieu encore
aujourd'hui en grèce des milliers
d'habitants des îles de lesbos et qui
haussent ont fait face aux forces de
l'ordre
on compte au moins 60 blessés après
l'intervention des polices anti-émeutes
les manifestants dénoncent la
construction de nouveaux camps de
migrants est le gouvernement appelle au
calme le royaume-uni menace de se
retirer des négociations avec l'union
européenne sur les relations post break
site
le gouvernement britannique dénonce un
manque de perspective sérieuse mais
espère que les grands lignes d'un accord
soit trouvé avant le mois de juin les
négociations post break sites sont
censés durer jusqu'à la fin de l'année
[Musique]
les mobilisations du gouvernement
français se poursuit dans contre le
coran navires us une réunion a eu lieu
aujourd'hui à l'initiative du premier
ministre edouard philippe qui a reçu les
chefs de parti les présidents de groupes
parlementaires et les présidents de
l'assemblée pour faire le point sur la
situation des mesures vont être prises
d'un commun accord écouter d'ores et
déjà nous avons désigné 108 hôpitaux qui
se tiennent prêts à recevoir des malades
tous les territoires sont couverts en
ville comme à la campagne en métropole
comme en outre-mer
nous avons commandé 200 millions de
masques supplémentaires qui viennent
s'ajouter aux réserves déjà constitués
et évidemment mobilisables nous avons
augmenté les capacités de diagnostic de
façon à pouvoir produire le nombre de
tests suffisants pour faire face au
développement au développement le cas
échéant de l'épidémie nous dégageons
aussi des moyens sur la recherche en
lien avec nos grands partenaires pour
mettre tout en oeuvre afin de trouver un
traitement et à terme un vaccin est un
peu plus tôt ce matin emmanuel macron
était en visite à l'hôpital de la pitié
pitié salpêtrière à paris c'est là-bas
avant-hier comme enseignant français
décédés le chef de l'état est accompagné
entre autres nouveaux ministres de la
santé olivier verront emmanuel macron a
été interpellé par un médecin sur le
manque de moyens dans les hôpitaux
le résumé de cette visite devant
l'hôpital parisien avec mona mode
emmanuel macron était en visite à
l'hôpital la pitié-salpêtrière après
l'annonce d'un premier français décédés
du coronavirus c'était un enseignant âgé
de 60 ans est le but de cette visite est
bien c'était de rassurer elle les
français de démontrer que le personnel
hospitalier étaient pleinement mobilisés
contre le coronavirus et dans un
contexte de crise où toutes les
professions sont dehors dans la rue pour
manifester
les médecins n'ont pas manqué de
rappeler emmanuel macron qu'il disposait
de peu de moyens écouter
le corps soignant qui dans son ensemble
a fait tous les efforts nécessaires
nous sommes au bout oui mais on a besoin
d'un choc chop chop d'attractivité il
faut absolument refinancer en urgence
c'est extrêmement important
je suis pas là pour moi j'ai compris tu
es je suis là vous savez qui est
derrière moi l'ensemble du course connu
et on peut pas se contenter d'effets de
manche je suis désolé d'accord mais on
est passé par un an et demi après on a
fait le constat
maintenant il faut agir alors moi le
fond de ma pensée c'est que kairos et le
moment opportun et le moment opportun
pour le président de la république
plagie même dans une situation dont il
n'est pas responsable c'est maintenant
qu'il faut saisir et va très bien j'ai
entendu je pense que je suis pas le seul
ok
mais merci merci que nous vivons
mais ils évoluent c'est quand il a fallu
sauver notre dame il y avait beaucoup de
monde pour attribuer là il faut sauver
l'hôpital public est en train de flamber
à la même vitesse que notre dame a
failli tomber ça s'est joué à rien et là
en ce moment ça se joue à rien pendant
cette visite emmanuel macron indiqué
qu'il fallait tout mettre en oeuvre pour
sortir de cette crise il a utilisé le
mot et puis des mines un mot que cib et
ndiaye a indiqué vouloir refuser
d'utiliser
quoi qu'il en soit une enquête a été
ouverte pour définir le parcours de cet
homme âgé de 60 ans qui est décédé du
coronavirus après cette visite le
président de la république s'envolera
vers naples où il rencontrera le premier
ministre italien giuseppe compter et
pour le professeur didier raoult et
directeur de l'institut méditerranéen
faction à marseille compte tenu des
dernières découvertes scientifiques il
faut utiliser un traitement contre le
paludisme pour soigner le coiroux
d'habiller russe alors la chloroquine
est un médicament qui était très utilisé
dans le traitement du paludisme mais qui
est aussi utilisé dans beaucoup de
maladies inflammatoires actuellement
avec des doses beaucoup plus important
est que moi j'utilise depuis 30 ans pour
traiter des infections avec des
bactéries intracellulaires et pour
lequel on avait d'ailleurs suggéré que
ça marcherait aussi sur des virus et en
pratique des gros virus qui sont dans
les cellules
moi j'ai traité 4000 personnes avec de
la chloroquine qui avaient des maladies
bactériennes chronique fièvre q et
maladie de whipple j'ai effectué des
milliers de dosage la chloroquine donc
c'est un médicament que je connais très
bien et que je suis depuis très
longtemps pour les infections virales
il a été démontré au laboratoire que
moins quatre espèces différentes
coronavirus était sensible à la
chloroquine au laboratoire maintenant
très récemment les autorités chinoises
est un composé mixtes de chercheurs de
deux régulateurs d'autorité ont rapporté
les résultats préliminaires d'une étude
portant sur plus de 100 malades avec la
moitié traités par la chloroquine et
l'autre moitié samples rocky
rapportant que ça amélioré d'une manière
significative l'évolution vers la
pneumonie ou s'améliorer les images
radiologiques ça permettait de réduire
le temps d'hospitalisation et plus
récemment un des chercheurs les plus
connus de chine
faisons vient de dire que quand on était
sous traitement par chloroquine la durée
de portage du virus et théo aux
alentours de 4 jours donc ça tu diminues
probablement aussi la durée de portage
et celui qui rapporte ça c'est le pin
homologue chinois le plus connu au monde
qui en appelait le héros du sart saison
et maintenant ces recommandations font
partie des guidelines de la république
de chine pour le traitement des
pneumopathies avec le nouveau cornaro
virus chinois donc sauf à dire que les
chinois ne savent pas travailler sont
incapables je peux pas faire autrement
que de dire que les chinois ont dit ça
et que comme personne ne pourra
démontrer que ça n'est pas la meilleure
solution parce que personne n'a autant
de malades et bien une fois adopté cette
solution parce que c'est la meilleure
pour les patients compte tenu de l'état
de connaissances personnellement je ne
fais jamais de prédiction en particulier
pour les maladies nouvelles si vous
voulez dont on ne sait pas du tout
comment elle évolue
par exemple tout le monde redoutait que
le sar ce2 évolué vers une pandémie
mondiale et puis brutalement juillet
2003 ça s'est arrêté et puis il ya plus
de cas donc moi je ne fais jamais de
prophétie ce qui m'évite de faire des
fausses prophéties et donc je ne sais
pas ce qui se passera je pense qu'il
faut être vigilant attentif pour
l'instant en dehors de chine
toute cette activité a concerné 35 ans
de chine aujourd'hui en tout et pour
tout dans le monde ait eu 35 morts hors
de chine avec le coronavirus chinois
peut-être que ça va devenir un désert
c'est pas sûr parce que beaucoup de
coronavirus sont saisonniers et donc
disparaît spontanément au printemps sans
qu'on y fasse rien donc les maladies
infectieuses c'est très compliqué et il
faut éviter
mon point de vue de faire des prévisions
sur 7
ces maladies parce que dans le passé
toutes les prévisions sur les maladies
émergentes se sont toujours révélées
fausses sans exception nous à marseille
pour pouvoir faire face à ces crises
épidémie puisque moi j'avais été chargé
de mission par le ministère de la santé
ni sa part cherché un peu moins de 20
ans pour savoir comment répondre aux
crises l'hôpital que nous avons fait
l'institut hospitalo universitaire avait
une des réponses aux crises qui
ressemble beaucoup d'ailleurs aux
hôpitaux qui avait été fait en chine au
lendemain du sart cinq mois j'avais eu
l'occasion de visiter à shanghai en 2005
et donc nous avons une capacité
d'absorption des affections aiguës très
rapide surtout si nous confirmons ce que
les chinois ont trouvé c'est à dire que
la période après le début du traitement
où les gens sont porteurs de virus n'est
que de quatre jours
ça veut dire que la moyenne
d'hospitalisation sera de 4 jours et
nous nous avons 75 lits d'isolement ce
qui veut dire que le débit est de plus
de 100 par semaine ce qui est beaucoup
rien de chez nous donc chez nous je peux
parler de la situation
d'ailleurs je ne la connais pas l italie
est donc devenue le pays d'europe le
plus affecté par le coronavirus 528 cas
et 12 décès c'est dans ce contexte
qu'est manuel macron s'est rendu à
naples aujourd'hui accompagné de onze
ministres pour un sommet franco italien
objectif relancer les relations
bilatérales devenu tumultueuse depuis
deux ans il est notamment revenu sur le
dossier migratoire écoute et aussi aider
ministre de l'intérieur ils sont revenus
le sujet de la question migratoire notre
coopération bilatérale est exemplaire en
la matière plusieurs initiatives ont été
rappelés d'avon actes et des contrôles
conjoints et une coordination plus
étroite au poste frontière
nous avons amélioré notre coopération
dans tous les domaines mais sur le plan
migratoire
il nous faut aujourd'hui ensemble
réussir à donner une nouvelle ambition à
l'agenda européen
les propositions qui sont faites au
début du mois de mars par la commission
et le sommet que nous aurons à tenir au
mois d'avril
sont absolument essentielles et je le
dis parce que nous avons destins liés
l'italie est un pays de d'arrivée vous
avez eu à subir par les années passées
des pressions migratoires extrêmement
fortes qui ont déstabilisé parfois
politiquement votre pays et l'europe a
eu une responsabilité j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire en septembre dernier
lorsqu'elle n'a pas été au rendez vous
de la solidarité et la france est
aujourd'hui le premier pays d'accueil
secondaire disons le de manière plus
simple et politiquement non correct
quand on ne sait pas traiter le sujet en
italie ça devient un sujet en france de
toute façon nous avons destin lié et
donc il nous faut aujourd'hui bâtir une
vraie politique européenne
d'abord de coopération avec les pays
d'origine
beaucoup plus ambitieuse ensuite de
protection commune de nos frontières de
gestion commune des flux migratoires et
de l'asile et de solidarité de
responsabilité commune et sortir des
clivages dans lesquels l'europe s'est
installée et nous avons acté de
travailler ensemble sur ce sujet ô
combien essentielle prix pour en parler
nous sommes avec paolo levi
correspondant à paris de l' agence de
presse anne ça bonjour bonsoir et au
pâlot lévy merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors le sommet un
qui a un petit peu changé de tournure en
pleine crise du coronavirus le président
mais kron qui a tenu quand même à
maintenir ce sommet c'est un message
important de solidarité envers les
italiens le président français se soit
rendu là bas c'est un message très
important d'ailleurs qui a été reconnue
cet après midi même par le mystère
étrangères italien luigi di maio qui a
tenu à remercier personnellement le
président de la république m'a cran et
tout le gouvernement français pour être
venus en grand nombre à naples parce que
cela signifie aussi un message très
important la communauté internationale
sur le fait que l'italie n'est pas un
pays à risque et que la vie doit
continuer donc continuer à venir en
italie c'est pas du tout en se
renfermant lancé propre pays respectifs
combat
combattre le virus la solution saas est
vrai aussi mais il ya quand même des
informations contradictoires les
autorités françaises diffusent
d'ailleurs des des communiqués dans les
écoles un petit peu partout pour dire
voilà on déconseille quand même de
voyager dans les pays à risque
on dit d'ailleurs au aux écoliers de qui
se sont rendus en italie du nord dans
les périodes dans les régions touchées
de ne pas venir à l'école pendant 14
jours votre aliment c'est très très
important de de le rappeler parce
qu'aujourd'hui on s'apprête à vivre des
mois assez difficiles assez inédit en
europe mais je pense dans le monde
entier et donc il faut être faire preuve
de bon sens pour que ce virus cette
épidémie puisse se propager le moins
possible et donc c'est la responsabilité
de nos dirigeants politiques mais aussi
de nous mêmes en tant qu'individu juste
de faire preuve de bon sens de se laver
les mains d'éviter voilà de les grands
rassemblements comme par exemple un
match de foot etc pour pour que ce virus
se puisse vite s'estomper au match de
fou turin lyon hier oui voilà
essayez thoniers écouter non je ne suis
pas étonné parce que dès lors qu'on
maintient les vols en provenance de la
chine dès lors on laisse les frontières
ouvertes etc ont fait un choix et ce
choix est tout à fait compréhensible
mais on ferme pas un stade
certes après la contradiction est dans
le fait par exemple que les élèves qui
reviennent de lombardie
doivent se prêter à une quarantaine donc
c'est à dire c'est soit soit l'autre
mais les deux choses ensemble parfois la
communication elle un petit peu confuse
mais c'est pas pour cela qu'il faut il
faut condamner les actions de nos
dirigeants politiques dans nos pays
parce qu'on est en train de vivre
quelque chose de complètement inédit et
donc tous
aujourd'hui on a un devoir de de tester
et aussi de responsabilité donc vous
êtes entre les deux pays en tout cas
vous emmanuel macron n'a pas fait
mention de défaillance possible dans la
gestion du coronavirus en italie où tu
es en italie il n'y a pas eu de
défaillance particulière il ya juste eu
une grosse grosse vingrau ce moment que
de chance c'est à dire que notre patient
numéro 1 qu'il n'avait pas une
manifestation claire et nette de lettres
porteurs de ce virus s'est présenté dans
un hôpital et il a infecté des gens plus
vulnérables qui était dans l'hôpital et
de la ce a explosé en lombardie
c'est un peu on va le voir si les
enquêtes mans le confirmer mais c'est un
peu ce qui est en train de se passer
aussi en france avec le patient qui est
décédé à la pitié salpêtrière et qui
avait été dans l'oise hospitalisé au
paravant c'est un petit peu la même
chose donc la chose à mon avis qui est
aussi la responsabilité de nounous les
médias c'est de répéter jusqu'à l'ennui
que si on a un petit doute
on doit pas aller aux urgences on doit
pas aller à l'hôpital mais juste appeler
le 15
détaillez le samu bien la maison il
vérifie qu on a juste une grippe et pas
de coronavirus et on est tous
tranquilles et on évite de propager
voilà la maladie chez des gens plus
vulnérables parce que pour le faut le
rappeler ce virus dans 80 % des cas et
même plus c'est absolument bénin on le
vit juste comme normal gré mais il ya
des personnes vulnérables qui peuvent
avoir des séquelles bien plus grave et
donc il faut éviter de les comptages et
donc en tout cas une entente un très
cordiale entre emmanuel macron le
premier ministre italien aujourd'hui
c'était important c'est que la relation
franco italienne a connu des hauts et
des bas rhin
ces derniers temps ces derniers mois
c'était important d'afficher cette
entente retrouvée
écoutez oui parce que on a vécu l'année
dernière notamment des mois très très
lourd avec cette guerre verbale mais pas
moins fratricide entre deux pays frères
de l'europe est donc aujourd'hui les
choses ont changé
matteo salvini et le dirigeant de la
ligue est sorti du gouvernement et on
essaye voilà de de célébrer aujourd'hui
s'être conciliation franco-italienne
vous savez on a beau changer l'histoire
mais on ne change pas la géographie la
france et l'italie resteront à jamais de
voisins de palier donc autant aller dans
l'entente parce que on sait tous que
quand on s'entend pas bien avec les
voisins y compris dans nos immeubles
parisiens c'est sympa croyez pas si bien
dire
est ce que on peut désormais dire avec
ce nouveau gouvernement compte et que
paris et rome sont à nouveau sur la même
ligne mais écoutez ça dépend des
dossiers
être toujours sur la même ligne je
dirais même que c'est presque un lieu où
c'était peut-être plus évident mais oui
absolument mais il ya un socle de
valeurs fondamentales qui sont communes
et je pense notamment à la nécessité
d'aller de l'avant dans l'intégration
européenne parce que c'est vraiment ça
qui qui qui anime disons le le coeur de
deux pays fondateurs qui sont la france
et l'italie et et après il ya plein de
dossiers et sur majorque migratoires et
aussi ses housses est d'ailleurs
compliquée de son tendre avec eux on en
parlera d'ailleurs tout à l'heure avec
les onglets ça se passe difficilement il
faut aussi s'entendre évidemment avec
l'italie pour faire face à cette
nouvelle négociation après le brix
absolument absolument il faut absolument
garder un lien très fort avec la grande
bretagne qui doit rester un partenaire
fondamental c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
sortis de l'union européenne il qu'il
veut avoir arrêté de coopérer avec
l'europe donc ça c'est un dossier très
important il ya notre dossier très
important qui est celui des migrations
et qui voit l'italie est en première
ligne
aujourd'hui il ya quand même une prise
de conscience de la part de la france
aussi d'autres pays européens qui
pendant une certaine période c'était un
petit peu détournée de la question une
prise de conscience de l'importance de
ce dossier surtout du fait que l'it des
pays comme l'italie
mais je pense même à l'espagne ou à
malte sont en première ligne donc il
faut absolument faire preuve de
solidarité parce que voilà tout seuls
nos petits états nations en tout cas en
europe ne sont pas en mesure de le faire
face aux grands défis du monde
contemporain et la question migratoire
évidemment qui était partant au sujet
donc de ce sommet avec la mission
européenne militaire sofia on le
rappelle ce que s'est créée en 2015 pour
lutter contre le réseau de passeurs en
méditerranée sur ce point l'italie
hausse un petit peu le ton si ça doit
être une
soupapes enfin je cherche le mot voilà
pour provoquer en tout cas l'afflux
d'émigrants ça sera terminé ce que
clairement cette mission est en danger
aujourd'hui la liste de s'arrêter on va
voir c'est au niveau européen que se
joue je pense qu'à la fin on va trouver
certainement un compromis sur ça aussi
c'est une question trop importante
aujourd'hui pour que les nations
européennes soient divisés sur ce thème
là et quoique les flux migratoires en
ont baissé ces derniers temps c'est
toujours un thème qui risquent de ré
exploser à tout moment et donc la
prochaine fois il faut absolument que
l'europe ne soit pas dépourvu ne se
fassent pas prendre de court par par
cette question il faut trouver un
équilibre entre voit la solidarité et
rigueur par rapport au micro que
malheureusement on peut pas accueillir
et aussi il faut une solidarité accrue
au niveau européen de répartition parce
que il y avait trop est double il y à
certains pays trop de pays notamment à
l'est de l'europe qui profitent disons
des avantages de l'europe et je pense
par exemple à tout
tous les fonds européens et ses droits
et en revanche il ne ne s'assume pas les
devoirs de solidarité par rapport aux
autres pays donc il faut trouver un bon
équilibre mais on va y arriver serré
comme dans toutes les bonnes familles
parfois il y à des frictions mais on va
y arriver
j'ai vraiment eu un avant et un après on
a retrouvé vraiment cette entente quand
même trouvé son fils en les voyant
aujourd'hui ils ont besoin on a eu
besoin les uns des autres
écoutez cette entente est vraiment une
nécessité
je vous rappelle que
que la france et l'italie ont des liens
historiques très très profond
c'est respectivement la france et
l'italie sont les deuxièmes partenaires
commerciaux donc on n'a vraiment pas
intérêt à se brouiller entre louer ce
sommet aujourd'hui dans cette magnifique
ville de naples avec ce soleil et ciel
bleu on est une magnifique manifestation
et représentations merci beaucoup paolo
levi d'avoir été avec nous correspondant
à paris de l' agence de presse en sa
merci à vous merci
que s'est il passé dans le village de
boot au cameroun anglophone il y a deux
semaines un massacre dans cette région
séparatiste a fait une vingtaine de
morts dont une femme enceinte et des
enfants mardi soit a mis en cause les
forces gouvernementales d une milice
poehl elle demande une enquête
indépendante l'armée dément toute
responsabilité les précisions des lames
et medjahed avec emilie google dans son
rapport human rights watch se base sur
des témoignages de survivants dans le
village de nous tous mots et des images
satellites
selon les ong les meurtres du 14 février
dernier ont été commis par dix à quinze
militaires du bataillon d'intervention
rapide unité d'élite de l'armée
camerounaise et au moins 30 peu armés
bilan au moins 21 civils tués dont une
femme enceinte est très enfants certains
âgés de moins de cinq ans les meurtres
de civils y compris d'enfants commis
dans des conditions horribles sont des
crimes odieux qui devrait faire l'objet
d'enquêtés effectives et indépendante et
leurs responsables devraient être
traduits en justice
des assaillants ont incendié cinq
maisons qui y ait de nombreux autres
biens est passé à tabac des habitants
les cadavres de certaines des victimes
ont même été retrouvés carbonisés dans
leur logement
toujours d'après le rapport de human
rights watch un drame qui a touché une
région anglophone du nord ouest du
cameroun en proie en sanglant conflit
séparatiste
que la régie le problème dont la région
préface n'est pas une affaire politique
n'est pas une affaire simple ce n'est
pas un problème lié aux élections
ce problème lié à l'état d'âme des
communes et qui démarre à cette partie
du pays c'est comme tomber me liée à la
aaa 30 ans de pouvoir
l'armée camerounaise a démenti l'attaqué
selon elle les morts sont dues à un
malheureux accident
les soldats parlent d'une explosion de
conteneurs de carburant qui fait suite à
des échanges de tirs entre soldats et
rebelles séparatistes
ces trois dernières années au cameroun
les combats entre militaires et groupe
armé séparatiste mais aussi les
exactions et crimes commis par les deux
camps ont fait plus de 3000 morts et 700
mille déplacés selon les ong
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les manifestations
des habitants de les eaux sont en grèce
entre un nouveau camp migrants le
gouvernement appelle au dialogue au
lendemain des violences et puis nous
parlerons les négociations prob rexie
qui s'annonce âpre entre britanniques et
européens il reste dix mois pour trouver
un accord
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut parler de fracture
entre le nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
vous avez deux pays de la zone euro donc
les pays du sud qui n'ont pas encore
retrouvé leur niveau de richesse d'avant
la crise vous avez la grèce et aussi
lit-on malgré tout les aides qu'on a pu
avoir au niveau de l'eau de la zone euro
n'a pas réussi à sortir de la crise
c'est à dire qu'on vous parle de la
baisse du chômage au portugal ou en
espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que tous les pays avaient notamment chez
nous en france des publics a augmenté
mais n'a pas généré de 350 je ne sais
pas qui est la locomotive de l'europe en
tout cas ne croyez pas que ce soit la
france
[Musique]
ah bon des femmes bon j'ai ma femme ce
qui a été une histoire jusqu'à
maintenant était biaisé
[Musique]
pour l'histoire de l'art d'ailleurs la
problématique est bien là pour
l'histoire de l'art c'est marginal il a
fallu vraiment des femmes génial très
très doué pour arriver à trouver une
place dans un domaine où rien n'était
prévu pour elle
[Musique]
ces femmes artistes ne s'en sont sortis
que parce qu'elle avait les tripes
vraiment bien accroché
[Musique]
e
la rivière tout moche chiot au delà du
cours moyen
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du tchoum la tente
traditionnelle et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
a du mal
personnellement j'ai grandi au milieu de
la guerre les sanctions internationales
et de l'injustice
on va voir un singe
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à travailler avec les
enfants abandonnés en 2003 après
l'invasion de l'irak par les américains
ma mère m'a emmené dans une autre ville
vous j'ai vécu avec ma tante
ma mère est restée un fallout york c'est
là qu'ils sont morts nous sommes donc
nombreux ils sont maintenant orphelins
comme nos maisons que l'on rejoint
daraîche et je n'avais pas envie de
rester avec eux si je l'avais fait je
serais devenu l'un d'entre eux
j'avais peur mais monsieur hicham a
commencé à changer ma vie j'aurais
peut-être a rejoint un groupe terroriste
ou un gang s'il n'avait pas été là ne
peut pas espérer que les enfants qui ont
grandi sans droits vont respecter ceux
des autres allaient mener quoi chaque
jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis relax chômeurs et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france répand soir à
tous bienvenue sur rt francs si vous
nous rejoignez 20h30 heure française
en grèce les camps de migrants loin de
faire l'unanimité sur les îles de lesbos
et de qui osent de nouvelles
manifestations ont eu lieu ces dernières
heures on compte plus de 60 blessées
dont une majorité de policiers anti
émeute
les habitants des îles expriment leur
refus face au projet d'athènes de
construire de nouveaux centres de
migrants cécilia chaude à l'appel des
autorités locales les habitants des îles
grecques vont jusqu'à l'affrontement
avec la police anti émeute nationale
objectif empêcher la construction de
nouveaux camps d'accueil pour demandeurs
d'asile et réfugiés
les installations actuelles surpeuplée
sont invivables
ils vivent comme des animaux à moriat et
ils veulent partir ils veulent partir et
trouver quelque chose de mieux
c'est ce que nous voulons aussi alors
nous nous battons pour eux et pour nous
le gouvernement a réussi à unir tous les
habitants de lesbos contre sa politique
qui allait créer un grand entrepôt de
prisonniers et réfugiés et migrants
nous exigeons qu aucun nouveau camp ne
soient construits sur les îles à la
destruction immédiate des camps
existants à la fermeture du camp de
moria la sauvegarde des frontières et la
régulation des ong
nos vies ont été détruites dans ces
régions proches de la frontière turque
et cela fait des années qu'on se plaint
de la présence d'étrangers
ce que demandent ces manifestants et
grévistes que les demandeurs d'asile
soit prise en charge en grèce
continentale pour être renvoyé le plus
vite possible
hors du pays selon l'agencé des nations
unies pour les réfugiés
avec près de 60000 arrivé en 2019 soit
le double de l'année précédente
les îles grecques sont le principal
point d'entrée de l'immigration
clandestine dans l'union européenne
entre afflux de migrants et intervention
des forces anti-émeutes les habitants
des îles sont à bout selon joel la
délègue historienne maîtresse de
conférences à l'inalco spécialiste de la
grèce moderne à lesbos chios mais les
relations au début était très bonne les
gens avaient eux mêmes le souvenir
d'avoir été des réfugiés de presque un
siècle avant et ça allait très bien mais
là maintenant elles ne sont plus très
bonne sauf quelques ya encore des gens
qui sont gentils qui résistent mais
c'est vrai qu'elle ne sont plus très
bonne et là l'originalité c'est que la
fureur s'est pas tourné contre les
réfugiés mais contre eux la police et en
particulier contre le ch est que le
gouvernement qui se doutait bien que la
population ne voulait pas de ces travaux
a envoyé en supplément des crs et là
vraiment ils ont trouvé que là c'en
était trop quoi cette c3 il consomme au
dos qui sont concernés il y avait un
camp qui était établie depuis plusieurs
années qui à l'origine était à peu près
convenable et qui était fait pour 3000
personnes
il ya douze à treize mille personnes
maintenant dans ce camp et il y en a à
peu près au moins 10000 qui font en
dehors n'importe où avec des tentes
un peu partout alors les conditions
humanitaires
les conditions d'hygiène sont absolument
abominable puisque ce qui avait été
prévu pour 3000 personnes ne fonctionne
pas pour 20000 donc il ya vraiment plus
ya pas eu de réparation ça vieillit tout
ce que vous voulez donc là dessus c'est
l'horreur il ya aucun doute on meurt pas
de faim parce qu'il ya suffisamment
d'eau renjie pour distribuer quelque
chose mais c'est vraiment où est le
projet gouvernemental c'était de
construire quelque chose de neuf
donc si possible à peu près aux normes
et qui pourrait contenir à peu près 6000
personnes et les gens enfin je veux dire
un des habitants se sont dit que de
toute façon 6000 personnes ça suffisait
pas aux besoins de tous ceux qui étaient
là et que si en plus on savait que
dorénavant il y avait des places en dur
je dirais convenable et humaines
disponibles ça allait inciter d'autres
gens encore en plus grand nombre à
traverser et qu'en plus ça risquait
d'être l'idée que dorénavant ces gens
finalement on allait les laisser là
alors on leur avait dit voilà les gens
ils passent par les bosses mais ils vont
aller ailleurs
et d'ailleurs les réfugiés eux-mêmes ne
demande qu'une chose c'est d'aller
ailleurs
et là ils ont l'impression qu'on va les
coincés là les aides européennes servent
finalement là aussi à assurer l'urgence
et si on transmet en fait elle
transporte très peu de gens depuis les
îles jusque sur le continent parce que
sur le continent on retombe sur le même
problème c'est à dire finalement en
faire quoi et pour des gens qui
finalement ne veulent pas rester là leur
but c'est quand même l'europe
occidentale et au regard de solutions à
part toujours les mêmes c'est à dire
s'engager
et à transporter un peu plus de gens
peut-être sur le continent mais ça ne
résoudra pas le problème parce que sur
le continent
là où l'état a essayé d'en installer
certains c'est à dire dans des villages
écarté où il y avait des logements
disponibles vous pouvez louer des hôtels
vides etc
on sait que la population le cas n'a
aucune envie de voir tout d'un coup de
doubler la population du village avec
des migrants général afghan c'est la
grande majorité est le même n'ont aucune
envie d'être coincé dans un village de
montagne grec c'est pas ça le rêve à
lesbos chios les relations au début
était très bonne les gens avaient eux
mêmes le souvenir d'avoir été des
réfugiés de presque un siècle avant et
ça allait très bien mais là maintenant
elles ne sont plus très bonne sauf
quelques ya encore des gens qui sont
gentils qui résistent mais c'est vrai
qu'elle ne sont plus très bonne et là
l'originalité c'est que la fureur s'est
pas tourné contre les réfugiés mais
contre la police et en particulier
contre le ch est que le gouvernement qui
se doutait bien que la population ne
voulait pas de ces travaux a envoyé en
supplément des crs et là vraiment ils
ont trouvé que là c'en était trop qui se
sent totalement isolés abandonnés avec
l'impression qu'on se dit que pendant
que les gens sont coincés en grèce on
les voit pas en europe on est content il
ya un peu de ça donc on leur donne un
peu d'argent pour les nourrir comme ça
ça ça évite quelques problèmes un peu
trop visible et puis voilà et puis
l'idée de les renvoyer dans le pays je
veux dire on peut pas les renvoyer
l'afghanistan n'a aucune envie de
reprendre tous ces gens la deuxième
nationalité c'est la series quand même
une guerre faisable et les renvoyer du
pays par lequel ils viennent c'est à
dire la turquie la turquie ne veut pas
les reprendre
londres menace de se retirer des
négociations commerciales avec l'union
européenne
faute de perspective sérieuse d'un
accord les relations post break ci
pourrait s'évaporer dès le mois de juin
un sujet signé mehdiyev kéfi si on le
pense est quasiment réglé le break site
ne semble pas prêt de tirer sa révérence
dans les débats quotidiens ce jeudi le
royaume uni a posé ses conditions
un ultimatum selon lequel les
britanniques pourrait rompre les
négociations commerciales avec l'union
européenne dès le mois de juin des
relations post break site pourtant
censée durer jusqu'à la fin de l'année
nous respectons la souveraineté
l'autonomie et l'ordre juridique
particulier de l'union européenne et
nous attendons d'eux qu'ils respectent
le nôtre nous n'accepterons aucune
obligation que nos lois soit alignée sur
celle de l'union européenne ou des
institutions de l'union européenne y
compris la cour de justice
au contraire chaque partie respectera
l'indépendance de l'autre et le droit de
gérer ses propres frontières
sa politique d'immigration et ses impôts
si le royaume uni menace de claquer la
porte des pourparlers
l'union européenne tient poursuivre les
discussions
britanniques et européens ont
normalement encore 10 mois pour
s'entendre sur leur nouvelle relation
bruxelles se prépare à envisager un
odile dans le pire des cas la commission
maintient sa capacité à se préparer à un
refus d'accord à la suite des résultats
de ces négociations
car elle continue bien sûr se préparer
un résultat utile et positive de ces
négociations
de son côté amélie de montchalin
n'hésite pas à pointer du doigt les
désaccords entre l'europe et le royaume
uni la secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes redoutent que le camp
britannique ne tienne pas ses promesses
les conditions d'une confiance mutuelle
ne sont pas réunies nous cherchons un
accord qui protège les intérêts des
européens
nous devons chercher un bon accord avant
de céder à la pression du calendrier 0
tarif zéro quotas c'est possible si li à
0 dumping mais cela ne veut pas dire
zéro contrôle nous aurons bien sûr un
mécanisme potentiellement avec des
clauses de sanction de rétorsion
sauvegarde si nous voyons que les
engagements pris ne sont pas tenues
entre les deux parties nous sommes
encore bien loin d'un terrain d'entente
et il existe encore des désaccords
majeurs comme par exemple l'épineux
dossier de l'accès aux eaux
territoriales britanniques notamment
pour les pêcheurs lundi prochain l'union
européenne va engager des négociations
sur sa nouvelle relation avec le royaume
uni sans trop de conviction dans les
positions sont divergentes entre londres
et bruxelles
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis liverpool au royaume uni avec
francesco gori totaux professeur de
droit européen l'université de
huntsville
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir afin de cette auto merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
britanniques et européens qui ont donc
dix mois pour s'entendre c'est le
premier round des négociations chacun
on connaît ça on a déjà vécu ça montre
ses muscles il ya beaucoup de bluff
peut-être surtout de la part de boris
johnson
jacobus amber collectivement soir vient
la voir un peu de la fin mais ce ne sont
pas à 10 mois en vérité la position
britannique
c'est qu'ils se décideront en juin s'il
y a eu assez de progrès nul donc pas
seulement du bluff parce que jusqu'à
présent effectivement barry johnson nous
habitue et ses méthodes un peu musclée
de mener ces deux couples et les
négociations et finalement il obtenu
gain de cause très rapidement a beaucoup
plus que theresa may évidemment qu'on a
vu voilà négocier longtemps sans aucun
succès je pense que il a très bien menée
c'est paris je pense que maintenant les
affaires sont beaucoup plus sérieuse
aussi on a face à soi les deux positions
sont extrêmement différentes sur des
points centraux aujourd'hui au royaume
uni on a adopté des mesures grammes de
cheveux concernant la subvention la
concurrence
le lin possession le travail les règles
environnementales
le rôle de la cour de justice européenne
a également été à traiter et le royaume
uni a dit non à ce mécanisme de
règlement des litiges
donc s'il ya un désaccord très bien ça
reste qu'elles sont francesco est auto
pour bien qu'on comprenne les points de
désaccord qui ont conduit aujourd'hui ce
que l'union européenne ait reculé de
120,6 pas que ce serait dans une
situation que égalitaire l'union elle ne
peut pas assumer car le royaume uni est
trop fort au niveau communal trop
importante pour que leur peine recul le
royaume uni pourrait faire du dumping
également une question politique en
france notamment un magasin en espagne
et dans d'autres pays autour de la pêche
c'est complètement très important ce
sont les intérêts fondamentaux des pays
aujourd'hui quel est le rapport de force
entre les deux parties
ainsi des joint-ventures besoins en
termes de poids relatif ignace il ne
fait aucun doute que l'union européenne
est puissante et c'est elle qui
bénéficiaient du poids économique
le royaume uni est dans une situation un
peu plus délicate
les gouvernements de boris johnson un
jeu met en jeu son avenir sa crédibilité
et sa légitimité sur l'obtention d'un
accord et il danse il reste sur onze en
menaçant de quitter la table des
négociations et de se tourner sur un
accord ce type australien au canadien et
l'union européenne a dit non pas les
canada mais l'australie pourquoi pas
c'est à dire les termes de l' omc
vous avez parlé 26 choristes autour de
la pêche qui est un des points
d'achoppement évidemment c'est
d'ailleurs à l'image des agriculteurs
avec la pac est ce que les faux pêcheurs
surtout français pourrait faire les
frais selon vous de ce break site
les britanniques introduisant une
certaine de licences qu'il opère sur la
base m
une réserve des poissons britannico les
pêcheurs britannique alors les pêcheurs
français souffriraient et je pense que
c'est pour cela qu'ils my mac rang et
c'est insistant sur le fait qu'il n'y
aura pas s'il n'y a pas d'accord sur
mall sur la page
c'est l'un de ses thèmes politiques
cruciaux et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que lorsque l'on étudié la plus poids
économique de l'industrie de la pêche
les bas si importante en général mais
politiquement parlant cette impasse
sociale et je pense que cela sera donc
un thème majeur
si vous lisez les complications toujours
à londres nous et que d'ici agent il
faudra voir les progrès accomplis sus il
ya quelques problèmes qui restent encore
alors on pourra peut-être continuer donc
il y a une certaine marge de manoeuvre
une certaine hésitation ne veux pas
aller trop loin
mais la pêche est en effet extrêmement
importante et l'égalité en termes de
concurrence aussi que se passera-t-il
s'il n'y a pas d'accord est ce que ce
sont les règles de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce qui vont prévaloir
au final tout à fait je n'en doute pas
un instant mais bourgoin s'il n'y a pas
d'accord reste ferme sur les subventions
de la concurrence le droit du travail
l'environnement
alors il n'y a pas d'accord oui bon
rares je sors une relation avec nos
mutuelles régie par les termes de l'om
c'est à dire qu'il y aura des droits de
douane des quotas est avéré exact mais
si on lit le document les deux documents
décrivant la position de l'union
européenne et du romain c'est très
important
il y a beaucoup deux termes utilisés par
l'om s'est donc on en n'est pas si loin
en fait le public doit comprendre qu'il
s'agit d'une négociation de divorce
il s'agit de mettre en place des
barrières mais pas trop hautains
donc c'est vraiment un monde totalement
extraordinaire construire des barrières
l'oeil n'avait pas et c'est difficile
comment éviter de nous blesser trois
lieux et tout en mettant en place la
volonté démocratique du peuple alors
dans les divorces parfois il ya quand
même des consolations les états unis
pourraient jouer un rôle important et
assez salvateur non pour le royaume-uni
lieu à défendre en premier lieu leur
intérêt est très clair sur ce point et
d'un autre pays
c'est tellement bien qu'elle ce jour le
syndicat des sylviculteurs disait que
tout accord commercial avec elle et je
n'y serai à du sursis on a importé qui
sont plus au boulot il avait donc là il
y aurait des problèmes bronca sur à
l'aspect sanitaire cela relations avec
les états unis n'est pas aussi claires
et bien définies que le gouvernement
essaye de le faire croire parce que
certaines personnes dans le pays n'en
veulent pas merci votre bateau car je ne
sais pas si effectivement états unis
pourraient intervenir merci en tout cas
à francesco gori doute au professeur de
droit européen à l'université de
huntsville d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france
le premier ministre et son équipe ont
prêté serment aujourd'hui en tunisie le
pays s'est doté d'un gouvernement qui a
enfin obtenu la confiance du parlement
un vote qui a eu lieu la nuit dernière
désormais il n'y a plus de temps à
perdre pour se remettre au travail après
quatre mois et demi de crise politique
et les médias aident depuis les
résultats des législatives en octobre la
tunisie était en quête d'un gouvernement
lors de ces élections ennahda arrive en
tête mais n'obtient pas la majorité
absolue le parti d'inspiration islamiste
n'est donc pas en mesure de jouer le
rôle pivot sur la scène politique auquel
il prétend conséquences en janvier le
précédent gouvernement constitué par
ennahdha échoue à obtenir la confiance
des députés
déception c'est une réussite
la démocratie tunisienne qui se présente
et elle est arrivée au parlement sans
avoir une majorité
donc quand on arrive sans avoir une
majorité peuvent vous savez ce qui
arrive on a perdu deux mois un désaveu
devant l'assemblée des représentants des
peuples qui pousse le président tunisien
à reprendre la main
cai sayed désigne alors eliès par phare
pour former un nouveau gouvernement
un choix risqué puisque son parti
ettakatol ne compte aucun député dans
l'actuel parlement
mais la semaine dernière et diane farr
farr trouvent un accord de dernière
minute avec ennahdha première force
parlementaire sans surprise son
gouvernement ont obtenu jeudi la
confiance du parlement tunisien mettant
fin à une incertitude politique mais le
travail du chef du gouvernement pourrait
s'avérer très difficile et complexe avec
un cabinet hétéroclite qui comprend des
membres aux idéologies et aux visions
différentes
quant aux tunisiens plus de neuf ans
après avoir chassé ben ali lors du
printemps arabe
ils les attendent toujours un
gouvernement capable d'affronter les
maux sociaux et économiques qui rongent
leurs pays
east et auteur de l'ouvragé de la
révolution à la restauration où va la
tunisie aux éditions riveneuve cette
nouvelle coalition va avoir du mal à
s'entendre sur les mesures économiques
qui est bien c'est que maintenant il
tient gouvernement que pouvoir s'atteler
au dossier brûlant notamment la crise
économique qui persiste la crise sociale
et même le climat d'insécurité
donc là moi c'est un signal qui est
envoyé aux partenaires de la tunisie et
surtout aux citoyens pour dire voilà
maintenant il y à il ya quelqu'un qui
tient le gouvernail
après c'est une formation qui est une
coalition qui est totalement hétéroclite
donc on a des libéraux avec des
socialistes on a des conservateurs avec
avec des mains des islamistes avec des
laïcs donc comme il ya cohérente sur pas
mal de sujets effectivement la vision de
l'économie est différent donc on a un
premier ministre chef du gouvernement
qui est social démocrate mais qui est
soutenue avec une part d
des partis politiques qui ont des
options économiques totalement
totalement opposé donc il avoir du mal à
faire passer ses réformes depuis quatre
jours à new delhi des violences
intercommunautaires ont fait 33 morts et
200 blessés les habitants musulmans des
zones touchées dénoncent les attaques de
milices extrémistes hindous la loi
controversée sur la citoyenneté
discriminatoire à l'égard des indiens
musulmans est à l'origine de ces
affrontements
une politique initiée par le premier
ministre narendra modi les précisions de
rania berrada et luca tué à new delhi
enterre ses morts
ces corps sont ceux des premières
victimes des émeutes qui frappent la
ville depuis dimanche des scènes de
guérilla à une dizaine de km du centre
de la capitale
les manifestations contre la loi sur la
citoyenneté jugé discriminatoire se sont
transformés en lutte armée entre
nationalistes hindous et musulmans
véhicules magasins et maisons incendiées
une situation qui pousse les habitants à
fuir craignant pour leur vie
les hôtels ferment les usines ferment
qu'allons nous faire
les gens m'appellent de mon village ils
sont tous inquiets qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
il vaut mieux partir que rester ici
pourquoi voudrions-nous mourir ici les
gens s'entretuent des balles pleuvent
j'ai vu des affrontements dans le
quartier depuis ce matin et je quitte la
maison pour cela depuis hier nous
demandons à la police d'appliquer un
couvre-feu d'envoyer des renforts mais
personne n'est venu
il n'y a que trois policiers on a appelé
la police plusieurs fois depuis chang
bague les gens scandaient gloire au
seigneur ram est rentré dans le quartier
mais la police ne nous a pas du tout
aidé pour tenter de contenir
l'embrasement
un couvre-feu a été imposé dans ses
quartiers depuis mardi soir le premier
ministre narindra maudit a appelé au
calme hier sur twitter la paix et
l'harmonie sont au coeur de notre
philosophie
j'invite mes soeurs et mes frères de
délits à maintenir la paix la fraternité
en tout temps il est important que le
calme est qu une situation normale soit
rétabli au plus tôt parmi les
responsables indiens des voix s'élèvent
pour condamner la passivité des
autorités
la présidente du parti du congrès sonia
gandhi réclament la démission du
ministre de l'intérieur
dans un premier temps maison expert en
relations internationales
je pense que les forces de l'ordre elles
de bissau aux instructions qu'elle
reçoive et probablement puisqu'il
s'agissait en grande partie de désordres
suscités par des milices intégristes
hindouistes et ils ont dans un premier
temps en tout cas laissé faire alors
aujourd'hui c'est terminé puisqu'il ya
un couvre-feu et que le préfet de police
du territoire de delhi a donné des
instructions naturellement pour que tout
cela cesse et puis on a entendu tout à
l'heure à votre avantage que narendra
modi lui-même avait appelé au calme
avaient appelé à la réconciliation alors
d'un hameau dit d'ailleurs ne tient
jamais des propos très durs vis-à-vis
des musulmans
il est 7h à son ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur ameet shah
et puis toujours dans son programme
cette loi sur le statut d'airé des
réfugiés qui peuvent acquérir la
nationalité indienne de façon assez
rapide à condition qu'ils ne soient pas
musulman et puis un recensement qui aura
lieu l'année prochaine tous les dix ans
et un recensement nahd mais les gens
sont un petit peu inquiet parce
qu'effectivement dans ce recensement il
y aura sans doute une mention sur la
religion et sur la date d'arrivée en
inde et compte tenu des problèmes
administratifs de ce pays
il n'est pas sûr que les musulmans
puissent trouver toujours les pièces
justificatives traite dans quelques
instants rester avec nous reviendrons
sur le corona virus la propagation se
poursuit
il touche désormais une quarantaine de
pays et puis nous parlerons de la grogne
sociale en france des syndicalistes des
gilet jaune des intellectuels des
collectifs tous appellent à rejoindre
paris le 14 mars
[Musique]
l'europe la france aujourd'hui on a du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'y passe les
chiffres sont bons
personne n'est content c'est à dire que
la désindustrialisation de la france
très très fort depuis 20 ans s'est
traduite par des fermeture de milliers
d'usinés
peu de gens osent le dire mais je le dis
il ya un retour en allemagne depuis une
dizaine d'années d'un mépris pour la
france parce que les allemands n'ont pas
compris qu'un pays adultes se laisse
désindustrialisé comme nous l'avons fait
et ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
depuis 50 ans on est en déficit que la
conjoncture soit bonne ou mauvaise
devant encore vous dire que vous vous
comparer à l'allemagne je ne rentre pas
dans cette approche des gens qui
sous-estiment l'allemagne et l'allemagne
est en fait dans son insertion dans
l'économie mondiale dans la même
position que le japon donc l'allemagne a
n'est pas foutu est donc la clé serbe
pourrait être l'entente entre la france
et dalmat la question reste sur la table
dans la mesure où ça fait dix ans que
les allemands bloc toutes les salles
historiques
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
comment ces deux n'englobent pas
seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici seul interdit d'interdire
ici on l'appelle la tour de david et
pour beaucoup de gens c'est l'endroit le
plus sûr de la capitale du venezuela
pourtant célèbre pour des taux de
criminalité urbaine très élevé 2500
personnes sans abri ont occupé ce
gratte-ciel inachevé du centre de
caracas
ils en ont chassé les criminels et
organiser leur propre coopérative
d'habitation
[Musique]
je suis venu ici pour essayer de plonger
à la limite de mes capacités
l'énigme je n'aime pas le froid ni match
c'est un défi en quelque sorte
essayez de plonger dans l'eau glacée
oh la vache
ce type qui a battu le record du monde
il a fait une autre plongée à 75 m je
dois plongé à 76 3 2 à départ
[Musique]
bonsoir merci nous rejoindre en direct
sur arte france pour cette deuxième
heure d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi
coronavirus le nombre de cas confirmés
en france est passé de 18 à 38
l'épidémie est entrée dans une phase
décisive selon l' oms six locaux vides
19 semble avoir atteint un pic en chine
il continue de se propager notamment en
europe
edouard philippe considère qu'il y à un
nid lieu d'avoir peur ni d'être
négligents face au risque d'épidémie en
france
cinq mois après le grand incendie
lubrizol mis en examen pour les dégâts
environnementaux du sinistre la société
soupçonnée d'avoir déversé des
substances nuisibles la justice prend
des premières mesures suite aux
conséquences de l'accident de rouen
survenu en septembre 2019
en france le gouvernement s'apprête à
avancer de deux mois la date d'ouverture
de la chasse soit aidé le 1er juin au
lieu du 15 août aujourd'hui la chasse
anticipé pourra-t-elle faire baisser la
population notamment des sangliers
si certains en doutent d'autres comme
les promeneurs ils sont tout simplement
opposé ceux des grès pour une chose de
créer pour une chasse sera anticipée est
il une mesure efficace pour une
régulation de la population est une
concession au lobby de la chasse
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
la mobilisation du gouvernement français
se poursuit donc contre le coronavirus
le ministre de la santé olivier véran
annoncé que le nombre de cas confirmés
en france et est passé de 18 à 38 une
réunion à l'initiative du premier
ministre s'est achevée en début d'après
midi à matignon edouard philippe a reçu
des chefs de parti les présidents de
groupes parlementaires et les présidents
d'assemblée pour faire le point sur une
situation délicate
elles ont convenu de plusieurs mesures à
prendre d'ores et déjà nous avons
désigné 108 hôpitaux qui se tiennent
prêts à recevoir des malades tous les
territoires sont couverts en ville comme
à la campagne en métropole comme en
outre-mer
nous avons commandé 200 millions de
masques supplémentaires qui viennent
s'ajouter aux réserves déjà constitués
et évidemment mobilisables nous avons
augmenté les capacités de diagnostic de
façon à pouvoir produire le nombre de
tests suffisants pour faire face au
développement au développement
le cas échéant de l'épidémie nous
dégageons aussi des moyens sur la
recherche en lien avec nos grands
partenaires pour mettre tout en oeuvre
afin de trouver un traitement et à terme
un vaccin pour plus tôt ce matin
emmanuel macron était en visite à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris c'est là-bas avant-hier qu'un
enseignant français est décédé le chef
de l'état était accompagné entre autres
du nouveau ministre de la santé olivier
et veyran ébène le micron a été
interpellé par un médecin sur le manque
de moyens dans les hôpitaux le résumé
avec notre reporter mona un modèle
emmanuel macron était en visite à
l'hôpital la pitié-salpêtrière après
l'annonce d'un premier français décédés
du coronavirus était un enseignant âgé
de 60 ans est le but de cette visite est
bien c'était de rassurer les français de
démontrer que le personnel hospitalier
étaient pleinement mobilisés contre le
coronavirus et dans un contexte de crise
où toutes les professions sont dehors
dans la rue pour manifester
les médecins n'ont pas manqué de
rappeler menu
kron qu'il disposait de peu de moyens
écouter le corps soignant qui dans son
ensemble a fait tous les efforts
nécessaires
nous sommes au bout oui mais on a besoin
d'un choc catch up d'attractivité il
faut absolument refinancer en urgence
c'est extrêmement important
je suis pas là pour moi vous accomplirez
je suis là vous savez qui est derrière
moi l'ensemble du cours ce que nous et
on peut pas se contenter des phénomènes
je suis désolé d'accord mais on est
passé par un angle déni après on a fait
le constat
maintenant il faut agir alors moi le
fond de ma pensée c'est que kairos et le
moment opportun et le moment opportun
pour le président de la république
d'agir même dans une situation dont il
n'est pas responsable c'est maintenant
il faut saisir les bains très bien
j'ai entendu je pense que je suis pas le
seul ok merci à notre hôpital
merci comme édouard
mais il a beau lui c'est quand il a
fallu sauver notre dame il y avait
beaucoup de monde pour attribuer là il
faut sauver l'hôpital public est en
train de flamber à la même vitesse
j'ai d'autres la mafia jambes et ça
s'est joué à rien et là en ce moment ça
se joue à rien pendant cette visite
emmanuel macron indiqué qu'il fallait
tout mettre en oeuvre pour sortir de
cette crise il a utilisé le mot épidémie
un mot que cib et ndiaye a indiqué
vouloir refuser d'utiliser
quoi qu'il en soit une enquête a été
ouverte pour définir le parcours de cet
homme âgé de 60 ans qui est décédé du
corona virus réunion également avec le
haut commissaire a tenu aux droits de
l'homme mme michelle bachelet a souligné
que la lutte contre la maladie devait
être guidés par les droits humains
réclamant que les mesures de santé
publique se fasse sans aucune
discrimination et en toute transparence
les quarantaine qui limitent le droit à
la liberté de circulation doivent être
proportionnées aux risques limités dans
le temps et sur les droits des personnes
en quarantaine doivent être protégés
notamment le droit à la nourriture et à
l'eau potable le droit d'être traités
humainement l'accès aux soins de santé
le droit d'être informés et la liberté
d'expression telle pour andré grimaldi
professeur émérite de diabétologie au
chu de la pitié salpêtrière mans du
collectif inter hôpitaux la situation
est sous contrôle mais elle peut
basculer à tout moment
ça fait dix ans que l'on fait des
économies sur l'hôpital est aujourd'hui
l'hôpital et à bout c'est à dire qu'à
des lits fermés en réanimation faute de
personnel si en plus du personnel est
atteint par la maladie virale sera mis
en quarantaine ce qui se passe à
l'hôpital de creil donc en risque d'être
un manque de personnel est en manque de
lits pour les patients très graves si
l'épidémie se développe alors espérons
que va pas se développer mais si elle se
développe
l'hôpital est en tension extrême 1 donc
bon que la raison de dire ses résultats
peut-être de dix ans de politique mais
il faut prendre des mesures d'urgence
qui n'ont pas été pris on avait bien eu
des petites mesures mais très en deçà
des besoins
il était prévu de demander 800 millions
d'économies
alors il ya eu un plan d'urgence où on
donne 200 millions mais ça veut dire
qu'on me demande encore 600 millions
d'économies
ça va ce qui veut dire diminuer le
personnel ne pas remplacer à secrétaire
qu'il part ne pas remplacer l'infirmière
qui part en retraite
et là il ya besoin de mobiliser du
personnel parce que a et délits parce
qu'on ne sait pas quelle peut être
l'ampleur du nombre patients ayant
besoin d'aller en réanimation
je pense que prénom la république se dit
que si une catastrophe alors que nous
avons injecté publiquement les
politiques en porteront la
responsabilité la mise sans terre et ce
besoin est parti mais elle est partie
avec un échec
seul hôpital public mais part pas avec
un succès selon l'hôpital public
donc si une personne je l'espère on a
frôlé la catastrophe pour les
nourrissons avec la bronchiolite
il y a quelques mois s'il y avait une
catastrophe de réanimation pour le
coronavirus il y aurait directement il
responsabilités politiques
donc je pense que prétendent république
et conscience là tout le monde sent que
pour le moment la situation est sous
contrôle mais qu'elle peut basculer
rapidement 7 et en italie
la france a un système de santé qui
tient encore mais nous sommes à loos la
vraie la vraie question c'est la plupart
de ces affections virales vont être
bénigne mais il ya 1 2 3 % de maladies
graves il faut les épisodes réanimation
s'il ya des milliers de personnes
atteintes
il faut des lits et des personnels
compétents 1
or là nous sommes sous une tension on a
évité de justesse une catastrophe au
mois d'octobre et novembre
je vois que mes collègues infectiologues
suivre ça de très près l'ensemble de la
communauté médicale elle est mobilisée
et après on peut toujours savoir cris
critiqué etc si on en fait trop on dira
c'est un missile sont en fait pas assez
ce qui est sûr c'est que si vous laissez
comme quand y'a le les pompiers on les
mobilise pas seulement quand elle veut 1
il faut que l'hôpital soit prêt or on a
traité l'hôpital comme une entreprise
qui devaient travailler en flux tendu
non un hôpital doit avoir des lits vides
et des personnels parce que il ya des
urgences alors cette sergent sans plus à
la particulière parce qu'elle peut
contaminer les soignants je vous redis à
creil les soignants sont en quarantaine
je pense que tout le monde est conscient
y compris les hommes politiques du
risque politique cette fois ci qu'il
prenne indépendamment du haut des
risques pour la population
donc voilà la situation et qu'on ne peut
pas traiter l'hôpital comme une
entreprise rentable travailleurs un flux
tendu donc sur la situation actuelle je
ferai pas de critique politique j'irai
aux mains de résultats il faut que le
président de la république prenne
l'occasion de dire l'hôpital ne peut pas
être traité comme il a été traité or
pour le moment
l'assemblée nationale avait voté un
budget de 800 millions d'économies
alors il ya eu une rallonge de 200
millions mais on est loin du compte et
le cordage juste risque de faire
exploser la situation
c'est un risque faut suivre ce qui est
dit comme précaution entre le lavage des
mains éviter les lieux de rassemblement
on n'a pas besoin d'être bon tout ça et
est quasiment du bon sens donc le
problème c'est que s'il ya une âme
démarre épidémique
il y aura des porteurs sains qui
transporte la maladie qui le franc 1 on
ne saura pas qui sont porteurs et donc
là on a un vrai problème et non ce
problème encore ces 3 ou 4 % de
personnes qui doivent aller en
réanimation est ce qu'on aura les lie le
personnel pour faire face si parce que
pour le moment la maladie beaucoup moins
grave que la grippe elle-même 1,1 des
problèmes d'ailleurs en france et que
beaucoup de personnel qui fréquentent
des personnes âgées et sociales ne sont
pas vaccinés donc ça nous fait réfléchir
aussi
voilà donc la main a dit pour le moment
est moins grave que la grippe mais elle
peut exploser alors qu'on n'a pas de
traitement
on l'a appris par le parquet de paris la
société lubrizol est mise en examen
en cause les dégâts environnementaux
causés par l'incendié de rouen le 26 et
en dernier les raisons précises de cette
mise en examen atteintes graves à
l'environnement et déversement de
substances nuisibles
la cause de l'incendié reste elle
toujours inconnue une situation qui
suscite depuis plus de quatre mois une
vive inquiétude chez les agriculteurs et
ce malgré le processus d'indemnisation
mis en place par l'état
retour sur cet événement noir avec
grégoire douce est une catastrophe est
encore beaucoup de questions en suspens
plusieurs mois après à 2h40 du matin le
26 septembre dernier une femme appelle
la police pour signaler une épaisse
fumée sur la rive gauche de rouen
s'ensuivent des détonations puis
d'impressionnantes flammes
surplombée d'un inquiétant nuages noirs
lusine lubrizol a pris feu les pompiers
ne tarde pas parfois mal équipés face
aux risques encourus
même situation pour les policiers
dépêchés sur place
après le désastre l'incompréhension un
sentiment d'inquiétude monte chez les
roux année peu d'informations concernant
l' incendie sont rendus publics
du côté du gouvernement la communication
est floue et la liste des produits
toxiques consumer publié quelques jours
plus tard ne suffit pas à rassurer les
habitants de la cité normande
il sait pas parce qu'on met sur un site
de la préfecture un torrent
d'informations qui pour la plupart des
gens dans la population est complètement
incompréhensible que ça veut dire qu'à
transparence si on veut que ce soit
sérieux et s'il ya des risques
sanitaires pour la population ce qui
semble être le cas vu ce qui a brûlé
d'abord c'est une enquête à long terme
qu'il faut faire nous on demande encore
depuis deux ans à 2h47 qu'est ce qui
s'est passé voilà de deux arrêts de 47 à
19h45 on veut une vérité on a des
témoignages de pompiers et d'agents de
personnes policiers qui étaient sur
place qui nous annonce qui est cité
l'apocalypse que
le problème n'a pas été gérée
convenablement qui le comme ils auraient
dû être
ils étaient démunis ils ont dû attendre
énormément de temps voilà ça c'est la
vérité que nous avons sur le terrain
des manifestations ont été organisées
pour réclamer la vérité dans les jours
et les semaines suivant lincendie une
mobilisation qui n'a pas empêché en
décembre dernier un arrêté préfectoral
autorisant une reprise partielle de
l'activité du site lubrizol pour l'heure
les causes du sinistre reste encore
inconnu et pour en parler nous sommes
avec ce nom de carvalho président de
l'association des sinistrés de lubrizol
bonsoir sinon de carvalho merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france on
imagine que cette décision de justice
est une bonne nouvelle pour vous c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour les citoyens de
rouen et ses fruits un mois d'un travail
des citoyens qui cherchent la vérité et
d'une avocate qui a bien fait son
travail
jean qui les avocats de notre collectif
julien massardier et donc 60 ans attend
beaucoup de la justice puisqu'on en
attendant très peu des politiciens qui
finalement ils n'ont pas réussi à saisir
7,7
justement cette opportunité de pouvoir
changer changer le fonctionnement ou en
tout cas c'est une bonne nouvelle
à nous maintenant d'apporter plus
d'éléments auprès du juge notamment sur
ce qui a brûlé rayonnement quels sont
les produits qui ont brûlé mon de
carvalho que ce qu'elle dit précisément
pour vous cette décision at-elle dit
pour vous cette décision juste on sort
elle dit déjà que dans un premier temps
il agrée une pollution une pollution
grave et dans un deuxième temps elle dit
aussi que
le discours de la grée allées du préfet
qui se veut rassurant en nous présentant
une entreprise très sécuritaire a
finalement nous en tant que citoyen on
avait compris qu effectivement cette
société le côté sécurité les c'est
vraiment à désirer
quand on voit le rapport de l'assurance
qui met en cause justement à les
défaillances et lahonce a pris feu c'est
là où justement il ya vis et ses
défaillances et et ses dirigeants n'ont
pas voulu écouter les maîtres et mettre
une sécurité meilleure sécurité dans
leurs entrepôts et et aujourd'hui on en
a suivi la toxicité pour vous c'est une
reconnaissance après coup de quelque
chose que vous aviez réalisé depuis
longtemps mais qui n'avait pas forcément
été compris au début de cette affaire
notamment par les pouvoirs publics les
pouvoirs publics
ils se sont prononcés déjà sans savoir
réellement ce qui a brûlé
évidemment qu'il aurait fallu d'abord se
prononcer a enquêté déjà savoir
exactement ce qui est logique quantique
à brûly c'est comme au niveau de la
quantité votre vidéo nous a parlé des
cas mais les quelques tonnes puis
finalement ils se sont ravisés et nous
ont annoncé que les entrepôts voisins
qui avaient pris feu ce qui rajoute est
presque est simple cinq mille cas
supplémentaire donc dans cette histoire
il ya eu trop de manquements une
mauvaise communication et est vraiment
nous en tant qu'habitant s'est senti
vraiment avant de lui c'est à dire que
on a manqué cruellement d'informations
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu une telle
ampleur on et réseaux sociaux et
qu'aujourd'hui on va chercher
l'information dans les réseaux sociaux
la parole de l'état ici à rouen elle est
remis en cause
on se souvient que de nombreux habitants
avaient des problèmes de santé de
respiration voilà de rhume quelle est la
situation cinq mois après tout semble
être revenu dans l'ordre au niveau de la
santé notamment au niveau des odeurs
lorsqu'il ya eu un phénomène depuis
quelques jours on a ressenti ces odeurs
je pense aux habitants de quévy et en
centre ville devront aussi on a senti
cette odeur d'hydrocarbure qui piquent à
la bouche
donc malheureusement cette odeur il bat
il vient au gré de la météo
donc on a compris qu'il y avait encore
qu'il sait tout ce magma qui était
encore certainement dans les haies ou ou
dans la nappe phréatique pour tous car
elle revient concernant les problèmes de
santé c'est sûr que comparé au premier
jour on est donc ça va un peu mieux le
voir mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les
gens qui avaient déjà des problèmes
respiratoires s'est pas arrangée avec
cette histoire du grisolles ça s'est
même empirée on a eu beaucoup de cas où
des gens qui s'étaient remis d'un asthme
bas ont rechuté et beaucoup de gens qui
ont des problèmes respiratoires
effectivement toute façon nous on va
répertorier un peu tous les tous les
tous les problèmes médicaux qui a eu
tous les problèmes de santé qu'il a eus
ont ressenti les gens nous on a un
travail aussi à faire là dessus
en tant que citoyen en tant
qu'association alors lubrizol est
aujourd'hui dans l'obligation rappel de
constituer une sûreté hauteur de 4
millions d'euros pour garantir le droit
des victimes en réparation évidemment
d'aidé au mas des dommages subis humains
et environnementaux
c'est une somme qui est suffisante
allons nous
notre avocate je m interdis et notre
association fait avec la fenvac
on a fait une demande d'accord qu'un
auprès du ministère de la justice et à
dire c'est une demande qui va permettre
d'avancer des fonds pour voir déjà un
des 1 une avance sur indemnisation vont
pouvoir payer les frais de justice les
frais médicaux
les franchises si vous faites intervenir
votre assurance après vous dire si la
somme de 4 millions d'euros est
suffisante déjà en moins ce sera une
provision qui sera stockée et c'est le
jus et aux victimes aussi aux victimes
de porter plainte et de de se porter
partie civile
ils ont subi un préjudice et sert elle
aussi de se manifester et faire le
nécessaire pour pouvoir être compris
dans cette affaire mais pour pas que ça
que ça recommence ce genre de
catastrophe qu'attendez vous des suites
judiciaires
eh bien on attend beaucoup de choses par
exemple miss nous ont fait un travail
sur les fiches produits donc de lubrizol
il ya énormément d'anomalies il y à des
produits qui sont inconnus il ya des des
des produits dont on ne connaît pas les
substances ou plus que partiellement
donc c'est une liste exhaustive comme ça
qu'ils continuent donc on demande à
l'église hall une transparence totale
comme nous l'a promis les ministres donc
donc il ya encore énormément
effectivement de deux ans tout comme le
côté on a encore plein de demandes dire
on veut obtenir la vérité et donc ça
passe par une transparence totale et à
lubrizol de fournir à cette transparence
et les éléments dont donc nous avons
besoin pour pouvoir exactement savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on a respiré séjour la
caisse qui s'est déversé dans
l'environnement dans nos rivières
dans nos campagnes dans nos aliments là
on veut savoir exactement quand on se
sent pas en sécurité
voilà on a besoin de savoir et c'est
normal de se voir c'est dans le bon sens
merci beaucoup sinon de cavalerie
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france merci à vous le rendez vous était
pris depuis un moment pour une grande
manifestation contre le gouvernement ce
sera le 14 mars au sein les informations
concernant cette manifestation
parisienne tombent au compte-gouttes
avant mon départ prévu à 8h30 sur les
champs elysées gilet jaune citoyens en
colère grévistes syndiqués les opposants
emmanuel macron ont signé aujourd'hui
une tribune pour un appel national à la
mobilisation
nous appelons chaque secteur d'activité
à nous rejoindre de manière unanime et
général nous appelons à unifier les
colères et les revendications pour faire
advenir un monde plus juste
montrons à ce gouvernement autoritaire
sourd et méprisant mise en place en mai
2010 est que nous n'avons pas dit notre
dernier mot que la flamme de
l'insurrection est loin d'être éteinte
n'en déplaise aux compromissions de
certains et en attendant l'examen du
projet de loi de la réforme des
retraites se poursuit difficilement à
l'assemblée nationale laurent piètre
alex qui le secrétaire d'état chargé
chez nos confrères de radio classique
laissons le temps aux parlementaires de
prendre leurs responsabilités et de nous
tous les moyens aux partenaires sociaux
de réussir la conférence de financement
arrêtons de dire des contrevérités les
réserves des régimes des retraites
appartiennent à ceux qui les ont
constitué
c'est écrit dans le projet de loin et
pour tauriac rouge gilet jaune
cheminot-es signataires de cette tribune
l'appel national du 14 mars est avant
tout plusieurs c'est d'abord une volonté
en fait unanime de ce qui s'est passé en
fait durant ces deux dernières années
notamment avec la colère des cheminots
en 2018 la manifestation enfin à la
sortie des gilet jaune en
2 me en fin 2018 et la grève historique
on a connu dès le 5 décembre donc c'est
tout ses colères en fait
qu'on aimerait se voir traduire en fait
pas recette mais cette journée de
mobilisation le 14 mars notamment aussi
des femmes et les familles des victimes
de violences policières qui seront là
aussi les écolos pour la marche contre
pour le climat donc toute ces
toutes ces colères en fait sont
rassemblées en une seule journée et donc
pour nous il était important en fait de
faire un appel à rejoindre en fait cette
journée il avait l'air justement de
parler comme un pdg en fait on reçoit
une heure entre deux cafés et on
essaiera de discuter mais on sait très
bien qu'il ya aucune
il n'y aura pas de sortie de crise suite
à cette réunion et puis
cet entretien puis une heure
pour faire quoi exactement enfin il a
avec lui les les
les centrales syndicales qui viennent
discuter avec lui
ça fait maintenant plus de six mois et
les a pas écoutés donc qu'est-ce que
c'est un coup ci gilet jaune
pour espérer obtenir un après ça c'est
mon ressenti mais faut pas non plus être
fermé à sa proposition après ça c'est
dans
ça sera la décision personnelle de des
personnes qui vont y aller
les acteurs de la mission d'information
sur le suivi de fermeture sur la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim se sont
réunis ce jeudi à paris edf doit
conserver la maîtrise de la sûreté du
site de fessenheim c'est ce qu'a déclaré
le directeur général de l'institut de
radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire
jean christophe niel ce jeudi pour
l'heure seul le premier des deux
réacteurs a été débranché le réacteur
numéro deux doit suivre le 30 juin les
combustibles usés seront eux évacués
d'ici à l'été 2000 23 le démantèlement
complet de la centrale ne devrait être
achevé qu'en 2040 à la sortie de la
réunion les acteurs de la mission
d'information parlementaire sont les
mitigé sur l'issue de cette audition est
l'avenir du site m'a rassuré nous a
donné des informations sur le
démantèlement sur le calendrier sur le
protocole sur les impacts
donc c'était attendu maintenant on
l'avait dit dans le programme
nous l'avons fait mais c'est ta route
déchets seront traités à la hague qui
est une usine est qu'il conçut pour cela
et ensuite le stockage se fera dans des
mines qui sont prévues à cet effet
souterraine ensuite
pour ce qui est de démolition on va dire
des installations il ya un programme
aussi est en place on a beaucoup
beaucoup d'attentes qui est reconduit en
la dotant dernier orateur beaucoup
d'attentes sur ce qu'on va faire sur ce
territoire comme on va organiser la
transition économique et énergétique de
ce territoire
et puis aussi comment ça va se passer
pour démonter le nom parce que là on a
vraiment un laboratoire absolument
extraordinaire qui va se mettre en place
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
ce sera notre débat face à face sur la
chasse avec le gouvernement qui veut
qu'elle commence deux mois plus tôt ce
décret pour une chasse anticipé est il
une mesure efficace pour une régulation
de la population est ce une concession
au lobby de la chasse
nos invités en débattrons
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut parler de fracture
entre le nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
deux pays de la zone euro et donc et
puis du sud qui n'ont pas encore
retrouvé leur niveau de richesse d'avant
la crise vous avez la grèce et aussi
lit-on malgré tout les aides qu'on a pu
avoir au niveau de la zone euro n'a pas
réussi à sortir de la crise c'est à dire
qu'on vous parle de la baisse du chômage
au portugal ou en espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que dans tous les pays d'accueil
notamment chez nous en france dette
publique a augmenté mais n'a pas généré
de croissance est lente
je ne sais pas qui est la locomotive de
l'europe en tout cas ne croyez pas que
ce soit la france ait j'ai entendu
parler de wikileaks et de julian assange
pour la première fois quand j'ai vu les
images filmées depuis l'hélicoptère en
irak continue à tirer c'est dégagé et je
pense qu'il ya des gens dans l'armée
américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
je ne suis pas pour la peine de mort et
puisque je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort il n'a qu'une chose à faire abattre
ce fils de qui légalement et oasis et
est historique
il n'est pas d'avoir un journaliste
indépendant
un type avec son ordinateur révélant des
crimes de guerre un large public
l'idée de développer une boîte de dépôts
numériques et anonymes ont un lien avec
le média qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté mais je
n'avais pas prévu qu'il deviendra
célèbre dans le monde entier si vite
qu'il serait à la tête de l'une des plus
puissantes organisations médiatiques du
monde aveux il avait beaucoup de
jalousie dans l'immédiat traditionnelle
envers wikileaks est en vert assange en
particulier pourquoi n'est-il pas plus
comme nous ils l'ont accusée d' étaler
des excréments sur les murs roses
ce qui est fou
et du orléans julian assange et à l'
isolement dans une prison de haute
sécurité attendant peut-être une
sentence d'emprisonnement à perpétuité
alors je ne veux pas le voir mourir dans
une prison américaine à l'infini et je
crois que c'est le sort qui l'attend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la veille mais idée courageuse
des mots qui comptent en soir vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
musée le matériel
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
l'huile de palme est l'un des produits
les plus controversées de notre temps
c'est une graisse végétale solide et
elle est très bon marché en 2010 est la
production a atteint un sommet de 63
millions de tonnes cette croissance
rapide de la demande globale d'huile peu
coûteuse à cause d une expansion massive
des plantations de palmiers à huile
ce qui entraîne à son tour la
destruction de la forêt tropicale
[Musique]
dans la seule indonésie plus de dix
millions d'hectares de forêts primaires
ont été détruits et cela se poursuit
[Musique]
21h30 heure française en direct sur rt
france merci nous rejoindre le
gouvernement s'apprête à avancer de deux
mois la date d'ouverture de la chasse un
décret en ce sens qu'ils pourraient
ainsi autorisé son ouverture dès le 1er
juin un texte qui suscite la polémique
ses détracteurs dénoncent une nouvelle
concession lobby des chasseurs regarder
[Rires]
[Musique]
le
[Rires]
e
[Musique]
[Rires]
e
[Musique]
taylor la chasse anticipé pourra-t-elle
faire baisser la population des
sangliers si certains en doutent
d'autres comme les promeneurs ils sont
tout simplement opposé ce décret pour
une chasse anticipé est il une mesure
efficace pour une régulation de la
population as une concession au lobby de
la chasse est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec yves vérilhac directeur général de
la lp o la ligue pour la protection des
oiseaux sur ce plateau à paris donc avec
nous clément peu qu'un association des
chasseurs d'oiseaux migrateurs d'île de
france
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
pour ce débat alors tout d'abord une
première réaction peut-être cette
nouvelle mesure du gouvernement qui
consistent donc on le rappelle a avancé
la chasse de deux mois à l'ouverture de
la chasse on parle essentiellement d'une
simplification administrative le tir du
sanglier était déjà possible pour les
détenteurs d'un plan de chasse chevreuil
à partir du 1er juin
idem pour le renard donc je pense que ça
ne changera fondamentalement pas grand
chose sur la pression de chasse appliqué
à cette espèce à l'heure actuelle il va
veiller à votre réaction vous même
plusieurs choses d'abord dans votre
présentation ça va tellement vite qu'il
n'a pas dix mille internautes qui s'y
opposent il y en a déjà vingt mille sur
le site de la consultation publique
ensuite j'ai envie de répondre à votre
invité six à ce fils ça change rien
pourquoi le pourquoi le faire nous on a
plusieurs problèmes le premier c'est que
on est en plein on vient en janvier le
gouvernement vient en janvier de
prolonger la chasse au sanglier jusqu'à
fin mars
il s'apprête à l'avancé jusqu'à début
juin
nous sommes en pleine période de
nidification donc il ya de forts des
rangements pour la faune et pour
l'avifaune les oiseaux en particulier
qui sont en période de nidification et
puis en juin
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que enfin
les gens ont le plaisir de redécouvrir
la nature soit pour le sport soit pour
les huiles et les loisirs
l'année dernière il ya eu dix accidents
de chasse mortelles
c'est plus que l'année d'avant il y en
avait eu
que j'ose dire cette donc allait
simplifier libéralisé et enlevé lé
autorisation ponctuelle qui était donné
par le préfet nous paraît vraiment
contre nature être contre nature clément
pékin qu'est ce que vous répondez à yves
moi ça fait des années que je chasse au
sanglier dès le mois de juin en même
temps que la proche du brocard qui a
toujours été pratiqué et ça ne me tue
pas en conflit avec les promeneurs je
suis pas en conflit avec les vététistes
je suis pas en conflit avec les autres
usagers de la nature
c'est des choses qui s'exerce à des
horaires crépusculaire qui sont rarement
les plus utilisés par les autres usagers
de la nature et jeumont pas mon sens
jamais fait remonter de d'accidents
mortels en juin mais au mois de juillet
mais bon alors c'est vrai que c'est un
débat animé on se disait en préparant ce
débat même en béton qu'on a tous assisté
à des dîners entre amis où vous êtes un
sujet qui est extrêmement explosif
potentiellement parce que les gens
voient là sont selon des avis le trait
comment dirais-je très tranché sur la
question
ceux qui sont pour sont vraiment pour et
ceux qui sont contre sont vraiment
contre alors ces accidents c'est vrai
que c'est souvent un argument qui
revient chez des antys h chasse c'est
pas facile à dire depuis 2000 entre 125
et 150 accidents de chasse qu'est ce que
vous en pensez quelle est votre réaction
quand vous dites pas d'accident en juin
mais il n'empêche il y en a qui sont
d'ailleurs assez un accident un accident
de chasse en occident trop on fait tout
depuis des années pour limiter
l'accidentologie des formations le tir
avec un respect d'un angle de 30 degrés
les tenues orange
les panneaux de signalisation ont fait
tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir pour
faire diminuer l'accidentologie et on
est seul voilà on fait tout ce qu'on
peut on peut pas en faire et on pourra
toujours faire plus il y aura toujours
une nouvelle piste à explorer pour faire
diminuer l'accidentologie c'est voilà un
accident c'est un accident de trop on
peut pas dire autre chose
après on voit là l'automobile génère des
accidents les vélos à paris les
trottinettes
il y aura toujours toujours il faudra
toujours faire mieux c'est sûr mais je
pense que
c'est l'accident toutes pratiques et
accidentogène est vraiment il velits
laquelle votre votre réponse monsieur
clément peu qu'un oui oui juste pour
dire que nous nous avons de plus en plus
de témoignages de gens sportifs en
famille qui sont choqués qu'on leur
interdise d'aller sur tel chemin parce
que il ya marqué chasse en cours et que
des chasseurs ou disent attention c'est
dangereux vaut si vous venez là c'est à
vos risques et périls
il va falloir apprendre à partager la
nature les chasseurs sont deux fois
moins nombreux que dans les années 70 il
était 2 millions 5
ils sont plus que hausse plus que si
j'ose dire un million il faudra qu'ils
nous expliquent comment ça se fait que
l'agrainage soit pas totalement
interdite en france dire qu'on nourrit
les sangliers pourquoi l'élevage n'est
pas totalement interdite pourquoi les
chasses en enclos ne sont pas totalement
interdite pourquoi il ya encore de
l'importation des pays de l'est ce
pourquoi il ya encore quinze jours en
ardèche
un éleveur de sanglier s'est fait
condamner pour avoir confié vendu des
sangliers pour les relâcher à des
chasseurs donc très clairement le monde
de la chasse a très mal géré le sanglier
parce que ça la range qui en ait
beaucoup et le prétexte est un prétexte
pour chasser toujours plus d'espèces
toujours plus longtemps la france est le
pays qui chasse le plus grand nombre
d'espèces alors si je m'en tiens aux
oiseaux qui est un domaine que je
connais encore plus courants les comptes
que la chasse et la la la france a
autorisé la charge de 64 espèces
d'oiseaux dont 20 sont sur les liste
rouge de l'uicn l'union internationale
de conservation de la nature
nous allons accueillir le congrès
mondial de lui c'est d'un marseille au
mois de juin et la france et la lanterne
rouge qui se permet de chasser des
espèces qui sont en danger au niveau
mondial
et qui chasse le plus longtemps dans
l'année en allemagne il ya trois cent
mille chasseurs et ils chassent sept
cent mille 100 milliers en france si on
a un million ils en chasse 600 à 700
milles cherchez l'erreur donc le texte
qui est soumis pourquoi on nous on va
nous tuer les renards on en tue pas
assez des renards on va nous tuer les
renards début juin on va libéraliser la
chasse au renard
si c'était qu'un poème de sangliers
expliquez moi pourquoi on y glisse avec
le renard et le chevreuil
j'aime bien parce qu'il ya des gens qui
veulent se faire plaisir à tirer les
renards au mois turin nous ont dit
qu'ils y aller il ya les jeunes encore
et que et que l'on tue il se tue à peu
près 400 milles renard au fusil et 200 à
300 milles au piégeage chaque année en
france et les français en ont marre
il faut que la chasse comprennent qu'il
faut qu'elle se modernise qu'elle arrête
d'en vouloir toujours plus que la nature
appartient à tout le monde que c'est un
bien commun et qu'il faut arrêter de
toujours vouloir en gratter plus clément
avec un l'annoncé a eu beaucoup d'idées
alors on n'est plus dans la sécurité
talent vous défendiez le dérangement et
les oiseaux et les périodes de
nidification
mais le fait de laisser les renard qui
est l'ennemi au mois de juin pour
nourrir les jeunes détruire des espèces
qui sont potentiellement en danger
ça ça vous dérange pas manifestement
vous êtes beaucoup plus agacés par le
chasseur que par la disparition des
oiseaux je m'en sers responsables de la
diminution du nombre des espèces
seuls deux responsables de la
disparition de l'avifaune de plaine
apparemment un personne ne va rien dire
d'autres lobbys parce qu'on est quand
même plus petit et plus facile à
attaquer alors la mauvaise foi sens
nauséeux
je suis ravie en france on est beaucoup
d'espèces à chasser ça diminue la
pression espèce par espèce non si vous
permettez il faut expliquer aux français
que un prédateur n'a jamais fait
disparaître sa croix si vous ramenez
l'histoire de la planète à 24 heures
l'homme n'apparaît qu'à 23 heures 58
minutes et quelques secondes et la
révolution industrielle les dernières
secondes et
croyez vous qu'il ya eu une disparition
des espèces pas du tout elles se sont
diversifiées parce que la solidarité ça
jouer donc non le renard ne fait pas
disparaître les preuves si vous en tuer
autant c'est parce que effectivement
pour lui c'est plus facile de manger
l'un de vos 15 millions de gibier
d'élevage que vous relâcher dans la
nature chaque année que de courir après
des espèces en bonne santé
donc oui effet facilement aux le
sauvetage et wendie renard l'a jamais
fait disparaître s'approche à kronach
consomme 4000 micromammifères par an
donc c'est un scandale parce que ce
c'est un allié de l'agriculture et après
on se plaint qu'il y à une soi disant
sûr populaire population de ce qu'on
appelle dans les campagnes les rats
taupiers et on va y mettre du poison
dont la bromadiolone qui enchaîne qui
empoisonnent toute la chaîne alimentaire
est-ce qu'on va pas arrêter un jour de
jouer au pompier pyromane ou de faire
comme les shadoks de creuser des trous
il est aidé les reboucher c'est bien
celle-là cette technique
moi ya quelque chose que ce qu'on fera
pendant que novice 1 sur 80 deux espèces
autochtones vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe pas chassables en france
trente-et-une donc sont menacés ou quasi
menacées de disparition comment on
explique cela c'était des chiffres
inquiétants parce que déjà voulait
contester ou autour cas comment voulez
que je ne permettrai pas de contester
les chiffres de lycéennes la seule chose
c'est que ces espèces elle traverse pour
la grande majorité d'entre nous notre
territoire
le prélèvement est somme toute
relativement peu importants voire
négligeable sur beaucoup d'entre elles
c'est une culture aussi de chasser
certaines espèces notamment certains
nicole du littoral que nous sommes les
seuls où quasiment les seuls en europe à
chasser et ça ne m'est pas non plus en
danger ou en péril ces espèces là ce qui
met en danger et en péril c'est beaucoup
plus à dire la destruction de leur zone
de nidification est la liste et la
destruction le râble la zone d'hivernage
mais je pense pas que franchement
l'achat soit le gros souci à la
pérennité
de certaines espèces après dans les
quatre mines micromammifères pour un
renard ses 5000 plus tôt mais j'ai mis
la virtual entre le 4 et 5 mille
micromammifères combien de la pro
combien de pouillard de perdre ô combien
de lovro combien de rats et de rats
taupiers fin de surmulot de la grille
l'avenir me démontrer tout n'a aucun
impact sur les espèces endémiques
je sais au moins je vous confirme que
c'est au moins 15 millions de gibier
d'élevage lâché chaque année pour les
tuer comme aux tirs au but gens mais
c'est dès aujourd'hui un bon jeu c'est
vrai que vous avez entendu parler de la
sélection naturelle
un run à un prédateur n'a jamais fait
disparaître sa proie
c'est impossible tout simplement faux il
ya des territoires c'est faux d'achat
notamment ont fait disparaître des
milliers d'espèces dans certains petits
tyrans déjà le char est par exemple à
féliciter d'espèces vous ou avez vous vu
que le chat était une espèce sauvage
ce sont les chats harets sont des chats
domestiques en lâchés ou évidemment
c'est un bras de fer téléspectateurs
yves vérilhac comment vous expliquer
justement cette décision du gouvernement
clément peu car prononcer le mot de
lobby en disant que le lobby des
chasseurs était petit c'est pas l'avis
de tout le monde
je vais d'ailleurs vous faire écouter un
son de nicolas hulot ministre de
l'écologie en son gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron qu'il y avait justement
déploré la présence de l'eau billets au
sein même du pouvoir à sa démission
écoutez ça va paraître anecdotique mais
pour moi c'était symptomatique et c'est
probablement un élément qui a achevé de
me convaincre que ça ne fonctionne pas
comme ça devrait fonctionner c'est
symptomatique de la présence des lobbys
dans les cercles du pouvoir
il faut un moment ou un autre posé ce
problème sur la table parce que c'est un
problème de démocratie qui a le pouvoir
qui gouverne un rat nicolas hulot
espagne et des lobbys effectivement le
lobby des chasseurs étaient dans le
viseur puisque en 2018 on rappelle qu
emmanuel macron avait donné son accord à
la baisse du permis de chasse
entier voilà qui passait de 400 à 200
euros
nicolas hulot avait d'ailleurs
démissionné dans la foulée vous dites
que vous avez vous un petit lobby pas
très puissant c'est pas l'avis de tout
le monde mais je pense qu'on est on
représente à peu près un million de
personnes
on est des utilisateurs de la nature on
est dans on est seuls utilisateurs de la
nature payant quand on chasse sur le
domaine public fluvial le domaine public
maritime
on paye à l'état une cotisation un droit
de chasse qui nous autorise à jouir de
ceux de ce plaisir qui est d'aller
chasser sur le littoral sur les berges
de la loire comme c'est comme c'est le
cas où d'autres endroits on est seul
city that her nature payant donc il ya
un moment je veux dire on a aussi le
droit de s'exprimer
non mais ça c'est pas contestable mais
bien sûr elle était gosse d'iridium
véritable ennemi on se souvient qu'il y
avait un parti présidentiel pour pour
les chasseurs oui j'aimerais que non
mais ça ne semble pas être sur un petit
lobby c'est pas comme veut dire si
vraiment lobby des chasseurs étaient
beaucoup beaucoup plus puissant il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on voudrait
changer
je parle en matière agricole je pars en
matière de restructuration des paysages
le retour dès lors tout redémarre le
retour d'un maximum de sites favorables
à l'édification des oiseaux l'arrêt de
la destruction des chaumes
systématiquement mois de septembre ou
octobre déchaumage systématique
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'autres pistes
si on était plus puissant pour
s'attaquer à d'autres lobbys qui nous
intéresserait dont on pourrait parler
bon iv lilac sur le lobby des chasseurs
petit à petit vous êtes d'accord avec
qui il est il est énorme et
insupportable il vaut celui de
l'agriculture et celui de la chimie
encore il ya dix jours seulement
la commission européenne a proposé à
tous les états membres 2
dakar dire l'utilisation des munitions
au plomb le plan est un neurotoxique
violent qui est interdit dans la
peinture qui interdit partout sauf les
chasseurs qui nous déverse 6000 tonnes
de plomb chaque année en france apparaît
zones humides où on l'a fait on l'a fait
heureusement interdire il y a déjà
quelques années et en à 2000 par le
ball-trap donc il ya 8000 tonnes de
plomb déversées chaque année dans le
milieu naturel des pays qu'on va pas
dire très écologique comme les
etats-unis ont interdit sont passés à
des substituts au plomb mais depuis très
très longtemps
or il ya dix jours suite à semble-t-il
une intervention des chasseurs au plus
haut niveau de l'état
la france s'est opposée à la proposition
de l'interdiction du plot alors que on
va y venir donc c'est une vraie
résistance qui a qui inquiète ont confié
leur apport pour limiter les dégâts de
sangliers à deux parlementaires
chasseurs mais autant confier la
question des 80 km/heure à l'automobile
club de france
ils sont juges et parties et ils sont
effectivement il ya un espèce de
décalage dans la représentation
nationale parce que tous les sondages à
80 90 % disent on veut plus des excès de
la chasse on veut plus qu'on nous tuent
des espèces migratrices en danger au
niveau mondial monsieur a raison quand
il dit que la chasse est pas le seul où
le principal
la panique chez moi on vous a mis
tellement s'additionnent c'est juste que
la chasse est juste en loisir c'est
gratuit donc pourquoi aller tirer des
espèces comme la tourterelle des bois il
dit pas beaucoup en france on tire 90
milles tourterelle des bois qui est une
espèce en danger au niveau mondial on
tire le courlis on est le dernier pays
européen à autoriser la tire et enlève
le tir du courlis monsieur parler
derrière des gens pensent que la moitié
des téléspectateurs ne comprennent pas
de quoi il s'agit mais mais c'est fort
intéressant parce que bon c'est vrai que
c'est un débat c'est passionnant clément
pékin j'aimerais quand même revenir sur
des choses peut-être qui il parle un peu
plus à tout le monde on parlait de la
sécurité c'est vrai que voilà avec des
morts qui sont amminex étape dans ces
conditions voulait lever elle-même juste
vous respectez vous même la
réglementation il n'empêche que 90% des
accidents de chasse sont dues à un
manquement aux règles de sécurité
est-ce qu'il serait pas possible par
exemple quand on a un permis de chasse
moi ce qui m'a frappé en préparant cette
émission c'est que là on a permis de
chasse à 18 ans sont eux devenir aveugle
cinq ans après on a toujours le permis
de chasse bon non mais je veux que vous
entendez
volontairement mais on ne pourrait pas
justement avoir des contrôles peut-être
plus poussée régulièrement sur l'état de
santé notamment des chasseurs
c'est sûrement des pistes qui vont être
à creuser l'idée est tout à fait juste
c'est vrai que contrôler l'état de santé
des chasseurs est important
naturellement les chasseurs quand ils
sont plus physiquement en état de
chasser ils arrêtent ils arrêtent parce
que la majorité des chats sont des
chasses collective notamment pour le
sanglier c'est la culture française de
la chasse en battue
sachant que au 1er juin c'est qu'on
n'ouvre pas en battue on ouvre à
lapproche actuellement donc cessons
échasses solitaire et qui demande quand
même une bonne condition physique de
marché pas mal et naturellement les
chasseurs arrête quand ils sont plus en
état de continuer à chasser
quand c'est vrai aussi il n'y a pas de
tabou on attend on en parle il ya la
question de l'alcool alors il y avait
sept ce sketch des inconnus on s'en
souvient qu'il y avait peut-être fait
date et que vous n'avez pas fait du bien
aux chasseurs que je fais mais c'est
vrai que voilà souvent dans l'achat son
nom
c'est l'après chasse plus que plus que
pendant la chasse donc c'est quand que
la chasse est terminée
en général c'est une tradition qui a
tendance à diminuer de plus en plus à se
perdre parce qu'on prend sa voiture on
rentre on fait de plus en plus de
kilomètres pour chasser sa demande
voilà s'intégrer aussi une vie de
famille à une vie complète et on peut
plus et enfin je veux dire je pense que
c'est la même consommation d'alcool que
celle qu'ils avaient sur les routes il
ya encore 30 ans et les gens repartent s
ou d'un dîner jazz comme hier partait
sous n'importe quel dîner oui voilà
et c'était pas plus la chasse une autre
raison qui les a fait boire faut pas
croire que la chasse est le repaire des
alcooliques des violents et certaines
ont certainement aussi fabuleux mais
c'est mal mais il faut le souligner
parce que c'est ce qui revient et c'est
au mois de juin quand vous cherchez à
5h30 du matin ou cinq heures jusqu'à
7h30 ou 8h c'est rare qu'à 5h30 6h ou
didier tient à l'écart non non non non
pas mon nez à louer
on va écouter justement willy schraen un
président de la fédération nationale des
chasseurs
après la mort justement d'un vététiste
tué par un chasseur c'est en octobre
2018 écoutez nous allons développer
rapidement des échanges avec les autres
structures et des autres fédérations
d'activité de la nature comme
l'équitation le cyclotourisme les
randonneurs pour pouvoir effectivement
rétablir une bonne communication entre
nous et il a aussi rappelé des bonnes
pratiques et échanger plus voir chez eux
ce qui va pas nous ce qu'on peut
améliorer et trouve effectivement
ensemble des solutions
yves vérilhac votre réaction d'abord
nous à la lteo nous avons plus de 40000
personnes qui participent à nos
animations nous n'avons pas été ni
contacté ni approché par le président de
la fédération nationale des chasseurs
je répands tout à l'heure quand même à
la question de on paye pour on est les
seuls à payer pour non je suis désolé
les consommateurs d'eau paye pour boire
de l'eau vous prélevez un bien commun et
c'est normal que vous payez pour
prélever c'est ainsi une forme d'impôt
et je trouve même un peu gonflé que dans
les cadeaux du président de la
république 40 millions d'euros ont été
offerts aux chasseurs vous l'avez cité
avec la baisse du permis de chasse de
400 à 200 euros pour le permis national
je vous signale qu'en allemagne c'est
entre 1500 et 5000 euros le permis et il
vous faut en plus payer pour aller sur
le terrain des autres ce qui n'est pas
le cas ce qui n'est pas le cas en france
donc ça nous coûte quand même un petit
peu cher tous ces cadeaux tous ces
cadeaux à la chasse et j'ai une question
à poser à votre invité en france sous
prétexte de tradis parce que viadeo
nettement il ya des chasseurs très bien
avec qui on travaille on plante et ont
créé des marques
il ya déjà des gens heureusement ça
j'allais dire normaux excusez moi mais
il ya des gens avec qui on travaille sur
les ts sur le territoire puisque nous on
est gestionnaire des espaces naturels
ont géré même une réserve naturelle a
été chasseur ça se passe assez bien donc
ce n'est pas une question d'être anti
chasse primaires c'est une question
d'être anti excès est ce que vous
trouvez normal que sous prétexte de
tradition et je vous demande vraiment de
me répondre
en france on écrase les oiseaux on les
en col on les étrangle et on les engage
donc moi je joue avec lui tient à
l'appui je vous montre des photos de
rouge gauche il se mange des brochettes
de pinsons des arbres dans certains
départements est-ce que vous en tant que
chasseur vous êtes fier de ça et
pourquoi on n'entend pas en france
la voix de chasseurs progressiste qui
dirait et ben non on va faire le ménage
ça on considère qu'au 21ème siècle c'est
la tradition à la bon dos mais non ça
n'est pas normal d'avoir du piégeage non
sélective qui fait souffrir les animaux
est ce que la vénerie sous terre qui
consiste à aller déterrer des plaies des
blaireaux en pleine période d'élevage
des jeunes de les écraser avec des
pinces est ce que vous trouvez ça normal
répondez-moi en toute franchise la
vénerie sous terre les blaireaux sont
saisis avec des pincettes eu à la dague
sont pas écrasés avec des pinces ils
sont saisis avec la pince parce que je
vous laisse le saisir à l'amant si ça
vous amuse
moi je mets pas mais man sur un blaireau
consorts d'entre eux - écrivant les
blaireaux je vais les regarder jouer
devant le terrier c'est un vrai bonheur
je vous ramène un jour si vous voulez et
vous arrêterez du genre de pratique la
vénerie sous terre est une chose qui est
tout à fait légale et autorisée
l'animal est sorti du trou avec dépenses
c'est vrai il est servi à la dague c'est
vrai sur les prélèvements de pinsons des
arbres
c'est une espèce protégée et - jaillir
je suis choquée vous parliez du pinson
des arbres
à ma connaissance personne n'a jamais
tué un pinson des arbres à côté de moi
mais quand le cas
brochen de rouge goélette cruauté
justement ces gamins ils voient bien
alors sur les ans c'est la guiterne à la
chasse à l'arrêt de la chasse à la glu
l'achat sur des règles lui est une chose
qui est autorisé en france
les animaux se colle sur des berges est
anglais c'est vrai c'est avec v avec de
l'huile végétale vous enlevez la glu
l'oiseau il repart mais actuellement
pourquoi vous dites ça mais est ce que
vous savez que la france va être
condamné
on est poursuivi il ya une infraction
qui ouvert par la commission européenne
malte a été condamné l'italie a été
condamnée l'espagne dans les prisons le
droit qu'avait départ de mon dernier
pays européen à autoriser cette pratique
est ce que vous êtes fier de ça est ce
que vous attendez la poursuite de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne et
que tous les français doivent payer des
millions d'euros pour que que quelques
milliers de personnes s'amusent à coller
des oiseaux et non il ne repart pas et
et nous avons des constats d'huissier et
nous avons été poursuites qui sont
engagés et le conseil d'état pour la
première fois dit on va demander à la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
parce qu'effectivement ça paraît pas
tout à fait claire moi j'ai toujours vu
des oiseaux repartir après avoir été
englués une fois les foyers repartir je
vous venez avec moi là non vous pouvez
pas le faire on l'a fait avec un
huissier et où je vous emmène dans mon
devoir les rendez-vous à l'antenne dans
ce cas fait la chasse à la loi de la
crise et de mémoire dans trois
départements dans cinq 5 5 départements
c'est pas les chaînes nationales c'est
une micro pratique et en plus ces
oiseaux repas ça c'est vu des sceaux me
retape et repart c'est ça oui vous les
embrasser il repart tout temps collé et
nous on les voit avec deux loutres
végétal vous nettoyez parfaitement la
glu c'est justement le végétal vous
pouvez acheter de la glu pour les
oiseaux en ligne je vous met les doigts
dessus monsieur vous pourrez pu
l'enlever arrête ne parlait pas ce que
vous savez pas le problème c'est que les
chasseurs normaux dont vous semblez
faire partie défendre des chars
inacceptable renseignez vous allez sur
le terrain avec vos collègues pour voir
ce qu'ils prennent du lion dans contre
le mois prochain pour nettoyer les bords
de loire vous merci messieurs en tout
cas merci à vous deux
ivery lac léman poker d'avoir accepté ce
face-à-face merci à vous et c'est la fin
de cette émission se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour 1 point complet
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable de nos
soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant est ce que
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays du sahel c'est là où
les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
par qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
un bon sapeur c'est quelqu'un d'être
agressif je vous dirais déjà à paris
sont peut être sûr qu aujourd'hui
pouvait faire tous les kilomètres vous
devrez pas quelqu'un on ne tourne on
plein mois de novembre à bien comme ça
j'aime double sauf l'anonymat l'anonymat
devait se monter ce bois tu viens de
chez toi tu vas au boulot tu reviens
personne tu as dit monsieur madame vous
êtes et les gaulois la vie est belle en
couleurs pourquoi diable blues
vous allez tous au noir bleu marine j'ai
dû nous c'est pas possible ça sert à
rien l'habille le sapeur fait jouer à
l'ebit son premier rôle qu'ils pensent
qu'ils ne devaient pas cessé d'être un
vecteur de communication
mais la sape basse et c'est sur le vivre
ensemble via la bi
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
ouais complètement vrai besoin
d'autonomie besoin de retourner à des
choses plus essentielles en fait est
vraiment de sentir qu'on n'est pas
forcément un poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour faire partie de cet organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps qu'on
reconstruisait cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres mais je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
[Musique]
là
coronavirus le nombre de cas confirmés
en france est passé de 18 à 38
l'épidémie est entrée dans une phase
décisive selon msi de kovy 19 semble
avoir atteint un pic en chine
il continue de se propager
en europe edouard philippe considère
qu'il n'ya lieu ni d'avoir peur ni
d'être négligents face au risque
d'épidémie en france en italie emmanuel
macron qui ainsi sur la coopération
européenne très étroites face à cette
crise de santé publique le président
français était tenable pour un sommet
prévu de longue date une rencontre avec
le premier ministre qui n'est à relancer
les échanges entre les deux pays le
royaume uni menace de se retirer des
négociations avec l'union européenne sur
les relations postgres excite le
gouvernement britannique dénonce un
manque de perspective sérieuse mais
espère que les grands lignes d'un accord
soit trouvé avant le mois de juin des
négociations fausses briques sites sont
censés durer jusqu'à la fin de l'année
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez la mobilisation
du gouvernement français se poursuit
donc on peut re le corona virus mise de
la santé olivier ferrand annonce que le
nombre de cas confirmés en france est
passé de 18 à 38 une réunion a lieu
aujourd'hui à l'initiative du premier
ministre edouard philippe a reçu les
chefs des partis des présidents de
groupes parlementaires et les présidents
d'assemblée pour faire le point sur la
situation et mesures qui vont être
prises d'un commun accord les nouvelles
personnes contaminées serait liée aux
cas détectés dans l'oise on propose
d'écouter le ministre de la santé
ce soir nous faisons face à une
augmentation sensible du nombre de cas
sur notre territoire
38 cas à 19 heures plusieurs
investigations sont toujours en cours
susceptibles de faire évoluer ce bilan
d'ici demain soir le directeur général
de la santé le professeur jérôme salomon
vous donnera des précisions dans
quelques minutes mais je peux d'ores et
déjà vous dire que nous avons identifié
un regroupement de douze cas reliés aux
malades identifiées dans l'oise qui
semblent liés entre eux par une chaîne
de contamination
parmi ces trois personnes trois ont été
diagnostiqués parmi ces personnes trois
ont été diagnostiqués sur une base
militaire
un peu plus tôt ce matin emmanuel macron
était en visite à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière à paris c'est là-bas
avant-hier qu'un enseignant français est
décédé le chef de l'état était
accompagné entre autres du nouveau
ministre de la santé qu'on vient
d'entendre emmanuel macron été
interpellé par un médecin sur le manque
de moyens dans les hôpitaux le résumé de
la visite avec mona amont dès lors
emmanuel macron était en visite à
l'hôpital la pitié-salpêtrière après
l'annonce d'un premier français décédés
du coronavirus c'était un enseignant âgé
de 60 ans est le but de cette visite est
bien c'était de rassurer elle les
français de démontrer que le personnel
hospitalier étaient pleinement mobilisés
contre le coronavirus et dans un
contexte de crise où toutes les
professions sont dehors dans la rue pour
manifester
les médecins n'ont pas manqué de
rappeler
à conques il disposait de peu de moyens
écouter le corps soignant qui dans son
ensemble a fait tous les efforts
nécessaires
nous sommes au bout oui mais on a besoin
d'un choc catch up d'attractivité il
faut absolument refinancer en urgence
c'est extrêmement important
je suis pas là pour moi vous accomplirez
le dire je suis là vous savez qui est
derrière moi l'ensemble des courses que
nous et on peut pas se contenter des
finalement je suis désolé d'accord mais
on est passé par un angle déni après on
a fait le constat
maintenant il faut agir alors moi le
fond de ma pensée c'est que kairos et le
moment opportun et le moment opportun
pour le président de la république
d'agir même dans une situation dont il
n'est pas responsable c'est maintenant
il faut saisir les bains très bien j'ai
entendu je pense que je suis pas le seul
très bien ok mais merci à notre hôpital
merci co victoire
il a évolué c'est quand il appelle
sauver notre dame il y avait beaucoup de
monde pour être élu là il faut sauver
l'hôpital public qui est en train de
flamber à la même vitesse que contre
l'ama faillite jambes et ça s'est joué à
rien et lens moment ça se joue à rien
pendant cette visite emmanuel macron
indiqué qu'il fallait tout mettre en
oeuvre pour sortir de cette crise il a
utilisé le mot épidémie un mot que si
bête ndiaye a indiqué vouloir refuser
d'utiliser quoi qu'il en soit une
enquête a été ouverte pour définir le
parcours de cet homme âgé de 60 ans qui
est décédé du corona virus et pour le
professeur didier raoult le directeur de
l'institut méditerranéen fiction à
marseille compte tenu des dernières
découvertes scientifiques il faut
utiliser un traitement contre le
paludisme pour soigner le coronavirus
selon lui alors la chloroquine est un
médicament qui a été très utilisé dans
le traitement du paludisme mais qui est
aussi utilisé dans beaucoup de maladies
inflammatoires actuellement avec des
doses beaucoup plus important est que
moi j'utilise depuis 30 ans pour traiter
des infections avec des bactéries
intracellulaires et pour lequel on avait
d'ailleurs suggéré que ça marcherait
aussi sur des virus et en pratique les
gros virus qui sont dans les cellules
moi j'ai traité 4000 personnes avec de
la chloroquine qui avaient des maladies
bactériennes chronique fièvre q et
maladie de whipple j'ai effectué des
milliers de dosage de la chloroquine
donc c'est un médicament que je connais
très bien et que je suis depuis très
longtemps pour les infections virales
il a été démontré au laboratoire que
moins quatre espèces différentes de
coronavirus était sensible à la
chloroquine au laboratoire maintenant
très récemment les autorités chinoises
est un composé mixtes de chercheurs de
régulateur d'autorité ont rapporté les
résultats préliminaires d'une étude
portant sur plus de 100 malades avec la
moitié traités par la chloroquine et
l'autre moitié sans chloroquine en
rapportant que ça amélioré d'une manière
significative
l'évolution vers la pneumonie ou
s'améliorer les images radiologiques ça
permettait de réduire le temps
d'hospitalisation
et plus récemment un des chercheurs les
plus connus de chine saison vient de
dire que quand on était sous traitement
par chloroquine la durée de portage du
virus et théo aux alentours de 4 jours
donc ça diminue probablement aussi la
durée de portage viennent on a appris
par le parquet de paris la société
lubrizol est mise en examen en cause les
dégâts environnementaux causés par les
incendies de rouen le 26 septembre
dernier
les raisons précises de cette mise en
examen atteintes graves à
l'environnement et déversement de
substances nuisibles
la cause de l'incendié reste encore
inconnue une situation qu'il suffit
depuis plus de quatre mois une vive
inquiétude chez les agriculteurs et ce
malgré le processus d'indemnisation mis
en place par l'état retour sur cet
événement avec grégoire dos et une
catastrophe est encore beaucoup de
questions en suspens plusieurs mois
après à 2h40 du matin le 26 septembre
dernier une femme appelle la police pour
signaler une épaisse fumée sur la rive
gauche de rouen
s'ensuivent des détonations puis
d'impressionnantes flammes surplombée
d'un inquiétant nuages noirs
lusine lubrizol a pris feu les pompiers
ne tarde pas parfois mal équipés face
aux risques encourus
même situation pour les policiers
dépêchés sur place
après le désastre l'incompréhension un
sentiment d'inquiétude monte chez les
roux année peu d'informations concernant
l' incendie sont rendus publics
du côté du gouvernement la communication
est floue et la liste des produits
toxiques consumer publié quelques jours
plus tard ne suffit pas à rassurer les
habitants de la cité normande
il sait pas parce qu'on met sur un site
de la préfecture
torrent d'informations qui pour la
plupart des gens dans la population est
complètement un groupe prêt en cible que
ça veut dire que la transparence si on
veut que ce soit sérieux et s'il ya des
risques sanitaires pour la population ce
qui semble être le cas vu ce qui a brûlé
d'abord c'est une enquête à long terme
qu'il faut faire le on demande encore
depuis 2 heures à 2 heures 47 qu'est ce
qui s'est passé voilà de deux arrêts de
47 à 19h45 on veut une vérité on a des
témoignages de pompiers et d'agents de
personnes policiers qui étaient sur
place qui nous annonce qui est cité
l'apocalypse que le problème n'a pas été
gérée convenablement qui le comme ils
auraient dû être
ils étaient démunis ils ont dû attendre
énormément temps voilà ça c'est la
vérité que nous avons sur le terrain
des manifestations ont été organisées
pour réclamer la vérité dans les jours
et les semaines suivant lincendie une
mobilisation qui n'a pas empêché en
décembre dernier un arrêté préfectoral
autorisant une reprise partielle de
l'activité du site lubrizol pour l'heure
les causes du sinistre reste encore
inconnu et pour instrument de carvalho
président de l'association des sinistrés
de lubrizol cette mise en examen selon
comme une victoire importante
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
citoyens de rouen et ses fruits vraiment
d'un travail des citoyens qui cherchent
la vérité et d'une avocate qui a bien
fait son travail
jean qui l'avocat de notre collectif un
juliana sardier et donc 60 ans attend
beaucoup de la justice puisqu'on en
attendant très peu des politiciens qui
finalement ils n'ont pas réussi à saisir
7,7
c'est justement cette opportunité de
pouvoir changer changer le
fonctionnement ou en tout cas c'est le
pen bron à nous maintenant d'apporter
plus d'éléments auprès des juges
notamment sur ce qui a brûlé réellement
quels sont les produits qui ont brûlé ce
ce matin
les acteurs de la mission d'information
sur le suivi de fermeture de la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim se sont réunis
ce jeudi à paris edf doit conserver la
maîtrise de la sûreté du site une
déclaration aujourd'hui de jean
christophe niel le directeur général de
l'institut de radioprotection de ce que
sûreté nucléaire le premier des deux
réacteurs a été débranchée samedi
dernier
le numéro 2 sera arrêté lui le 30 juin
les acteurs de la mission d'information
parlementaire sondés mitigé sur l'issue
de cette audition est l'avenir du site
m'a rassuré nous a donné des
informations sur le démantèlement sur le
calendrier sur le protocole sur les
impacts
donc c'était attendu maintenant on
l'avait dit dans le programme
nous l'avons fait et c'est ta route
déchets seront traités à la hague que
tunisie n'est qu'il conçut pour cela et
ensuite le stockage se fera dans des
mines qui sont prévues à cet effet
souterraine ensuite
pour ce qui est de démolition on va dire
des installations il ya un programme
aussi qu'il est en place on a beaucoup
beaucoup d'attentes qui ressemble un
dernier orateur aux attentes sur ce
qu'on va faire sur ce territoire comme
on va organiser la transition économique
et énergétique de ce territoire
et puis aussi comment ça va se passer
pour démantèlement parce que là on a
vraiment un laboratoire absolument
extraordinaire qui va se mettre en place
mais l'italie est donc devenue le pays
d'europe le plus affecté par le corps
d'un virus 528 cas 12 décès c'est dans
ce contexte
emmanuel macron s'est rendu à naples
aujourd'hui accompagné de onze ministres
pour un sommet franco italien objectif
relancer les relations bilatérales
devenu tumultueuse depuis deux ans il
est notamment revenu sur le dossier
migratoire écouter et aussi aider
ministre de l'intérieur ils sont revenus
le sujet de la question
la question migratoire notre coopération
bilatérale est exemplaire en la matière
plusieurs initiatives ont été rappelés
d'avon actes et des contrôles conjoints
et une coordination plus étroite au
poste frontière
nous avons amélioré notre coopération
dans tous les domaines mais sur le plan
migratoire
il nous faut aujourd'hui ensemble
réussir à donner une nouvelle ambition à
l'agenda européen
les propositions qui sont faites au
début du mois de mars par la commission
et le sommet que nous aurons à tenir au
mois d'avril sont absolument
essentielles et je le dis parce que nous
avons destins liés
l'italie est un pays d'arrivée vous avez
eu à subir par les années passées des
pressions migratoires extrêmement fortes
qui ont déstabilisé parfois
politiquement votre pays et l'europe a
eu une responsabilité j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire en septembre dernier
lorsqu'elle n'a pas été au rendez vous
de la solidarité et la france est
aujourd'hui le premier pays d'accueil
secondaire disons le de manière plus
simple et politiquement non correct
quand on ne sait pas traiter le sujet en
italie ça devient un sujet en france de
toute façon nous avons destin lié et
donc il nous faut aujourd'hui bâtir une
vraie politique européenne
d'abord de coopération avec les pays
d'origine beaucoup plus ambitieuse
ensuite de protection commune de nos
frontières de gestion commune des flux
migratoires et de l'asile et de
solidarité de responsabilité commune et
sortir des clivages dans lesquels
l'europe s'est installée et nous avons
invité de travailler ensemble sur ce
sujet ô combien essentielle et nous
avons parlé de cette rencontre tout à
l'heure avec paolo levi correspondant à
paris de l' agence de presse hans a pour
lui un rapprochement entre rome et paris
est une bonne chose pour les venir
écouter oui parce que on a vécu l'année
dernière notamment des mois très très
lourd avec cette guerre verbale mais pas
moins fratricide entre deux pays frères
de l'europe est donc aujourd'hui les
choses ont changé
matteo salvini et le dirigeant de la
ligue est sorti du gouvernement et on
essaye voilà de de célébrer aujourd'hui
cette réconciliation franco italienne
vous savez on a beau changer l'histoire
mais on ne change pas la géographie la
france et l'italie resteront à jamais de
voisins de palier donc autant aller dans
l'entente parce que on sait tous que
quand on s'entend pas bien avec les
voisins y compris dans nos immeubles
parisiens c'est pas très sympa
londres menace de se retirer des
négociations commerciales avec l'union
européenne faute de perspective sérieuse
d'un accord les relations poste précis
pourrait s'évaporer dès le mois de juin
sujet signé mehdi skis si on le pense
est quasiment réglé le break site ne
semble pas prêt de tirer sa révérence
dans les débats quotidiens ce jeudi le
royaume uni a posé ses conditions
un ultimatum selon lequel les
britanniques pourrait rompre les
négociations commerciales avec l'union
européenne dès le mois de juin des
relations post break site pourtant
censée durer jusqu'à la fin de l'année
nous respectons la souveraineté
l'autonomie et l'ordre juridique
particulier de l'union européenne et
nous attendons d'eux qu'ils respectent
le nôtre nous n'accepterons aucune
obligation que la loi soit alignée sur
celle de l'union européenne ou des
institutions de l'union européenne y
compris la cour de justice
au contraire chaque partie respectera
l'indépendance de l'autre et le droit de
gérer ses propres frontières
sa politique d'immigration et c'est
important si le royaume uni menace de
claquer la porte des pourparlers
l'union européenne tient poursuivre les
discussions
britanniques et européens ont
normalement encore 10 mois pour
s'entendre sur leur nouvelle relation
bruxelles se prépare à envisager un
odile dans le pire des cas la commission
maintient sa capacité à se préparer à un
refus d'accord à la suite des résultats
de ces négociations
car elle continue bien sûr se préparer
un résultat utile et positive de ces
négociations
de son côté amélie de montchalin
n'hésite pas à pointer du doigt les
désaccords entre l'europe et le royaume
uni la secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes redoutent que le camp
britannique ne tienne pas ses promesses
les conditions d'une confiance mutuelle
ne sont pas réunies nous cherchons un
accord qui protège les intérêts des
européens
nous devons chercher un bon accord avant
de céder à la pression du calendrier 0
tarif zéro quotas c'est possible si les
héros dumping mais cela ne veut pas dire
zéro contrôle nous aurons bien sûr un
mécanisme potentiellement avec des
clauses de sanction de rétorsion de
sauvegarde
si nous voyons que les engagements pris
ne sont pas tenues entre les deux
parties nous sommes encore bien loin
d'un terrain d'entente et il existe
encore des désaccords majeurs comme par
exemple l'épineux dossier de l'accès aux
eaux territoriales britanniques
notamment pour les pêcheurs lundi
prochain l'union européenne va engager
la négociation sur sa nouvelle relation
avec le royaume uni sans trop de
conviction dans les positions sont
divergentes entre londres et bruxelles
et pour franz och francesco gori totaux
au professeur de droit à l'université de
réduit l'union européenne ne peut pas se
permettre de reculer parce que l'union
européenne reculeront de la suite pensé
que ce serait dans une situation
égalitaire à la mairie l'union
européenne ne peut pas rouvrir kara le
royaume uni est trop fort au niveau de
menace trop importante pour que ne
reprenne recul le royaume uni pourrait
faire du dumping également une question
politique en france notamment un magasin
en espagne et dans d'autres pays autour
de la pêche c'est complètement un
obstacle très important ce sont les
intérêts fondamentaux des pays bas
sneijder termes de poids relatif signal
il ne fait aucun doute que l'union
européenne est puissante et c'est elle
qui bénéficient et du poids économique
le royaume uni est dans une situation un
peu plus délicate
le premier ministre et son équipe ont
prêté serment aujourd'hui en tunisie le
pays s'est doté d'un gouvernement qui a
enfin obtenu la confiance du parlement
un vote qui a eu lieu la nuit dernière
les ans mais il n'y a plus de temps à
perdre pour se remettre au travail après
quatre mois et demi de crise politique
et la maîtresse depuis les résultats des
législatives en octobre la tunisie était
en quête d'un gouvernement
lors de ces élections ennahda arrive en
tête mais n'obtient pas la majorité
absolue le parti d'inspiration islamiste
n'est donc pas en mesure de jouer le
rôle pivot sur la scène politique auquel
il prétend conséquences
en janvier le précédent gouvernement
constitué par ennahdha échoue à obtenir
la confiance des députés
c'est pas une déception c'est une
réussite
la démocratie tunisienne voilà un
gouvernement qui se présentent à l'air
et il sera elle est arrivée au parlement
sans avoir une majorité
donc quand on arrive sans avoir une
majorité va vous savez ce qui arrive on
a perdu deux mois un désaveu devant
l'assemblée des représentants des
peuples qui pousse le président tunisien
à reprendre la main cai sayed désigne
alors eliès farfar pour former un
nouveau gouvernement
un choix risqué puisque son parti est à
14 ne compte aucun député dans l'actuel
parlement
mais la semaine dernière et diesse
farfar trouvent un accord de dernière
minute avec ennahdha première force
parlementaire sans surprise son
gouvernement ont obtenu jeudi la
confiance du parlement tunisien mettant
fin à une incertitude politique mais le
travail du chef du gouvernement pourrait
s'avérer très difficile et complexe avec
un cabinet hétéroclite qui comprend des
membres aux idéologies et aux visions
différentes
quant aux tunisiens plus de neuf ans
après avoir chassé ben ali lors du
printemps arabe et les attendent
toujours un gouvernement capable
d'affronter les maux sociaux économiques
qui rongent leurs pays
et pour un thème nef qui essayiste et
auteur de l'ouvragé de la révolution à
la restauration ou valait tunisie aux
éditions riveneuve cette nouvelle
coalition va avoir du mal à s'entendre
sur les mesures économiques qui est bien
c'est que maintenant il tient un
gouvernement qui pouvoir s'atteler au
dossier brûlant notamment la crise
économique qui persiste la crise sociale
et même le climat d'insécurité
donc là moi c'est un signal qui est
envoyé aux partenaires de la tunisie et
surtout citoyens pour dire voilà
maintenant il y à il ya quelqu'un qui
tient le gouvernail
après c'est une formation qui est une
coalition qui est totalement hétéroclite
donc on a des libéraux avec t
des socialistes on a des conservateurs
avec avec des mains des islamistes avec
des laïcs donc comme si incohérente sur
pas mal de sujets effectivement la
vision de l'économie et différents dont
un premier ministre
enfin chef du gouvernement qui est
social démocrate mais qui est soutenue
avec une part d des partis politiques
qui vont des options économiques
totalement totalement opposé donc il
avoir du mal à faire passer ses réformes
la russie accuse les turcs de violer un
accord à propos de la syrie le président
r douanes s'apprête lui à convoquer un
conseil extraordinaire sur la question
alors que neuf soldats turcs ont été
tués selon ankara
moscou estime qu'en soutenons les
opposants au gouvernement syrien la
turquie ne respectait pas l'accord de
sotchi conclu en 2018 dans la province
d'idlib la ville stratégique de saraqeb
a été reprise par les groupes armés
soutenus par ankara a dans le même temps
les forces gouvernementales syriennes
appuyées par la russie ont repris une
vingtaine d'autres localités de la
région
et puis la porte parole du ministère
russe des affaires étrangères a réagi à
la situation
signe en ce qui concerne la résolution
de la situation au tibet autour du libre
le fait que l'on cherche à lier
l'organisation de nos consultations
bilatérales à des formats multilatéraux
qui existent déjà ou qui sont
susceptibles d'apparaître y compris le
format que vous avez évoqué ensuite en
matière douanes c'est un peu étrange
s'il s'agit de questions bilatérales
elles doivent être discutées au sein de
formats bilatéraux pour cela il y
actuellement des consultations qui je
pense vont durer quelques jours
quant au fait d'ajouter à d'autres pays
surtout des pays qui à mon sens n'ont
pas joué un rôle essentiel dans la
situation au sol une question qui s'en
posent pourquoi est ce nécessaire
[Musique]
coaching n'y a pas dit mais le
gouvernement s'apprête à avancer de deux
mois la date d'ouverture de la chasse un
décret en ce sens pourrait être ainsi
autorisé son ouverture dès le 1er juin
un texte qui suscite la polémique
ses détracteurs dénoncent une nouvelle
concession lobby des chasseurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
[Rires]
[Musique]
et dans notre face à face ce soir nos
invités sont revenus sur les nombreuses
espèces chassées en france aujourd'hui
dont certaines sont en danger jeu qu'on
propose de les écouter en la france est
le pays qui chasse le plus grand nombre
d'espèces alors si je m'en tiens aux
oiseaux qui est un domaine que je
connais encore plus pour en est content
que la sha la la la france a autorisé
l'achat de 64 espèces d'oiseaux dont 20
sont les sur les liste rouge de l'uicn
l'union internationale de conservation
de la nature
nous allons accueillir le congrès
mondial de lui c'est d'un marseille au
mois de juin et la france et la lanterne
rouge qui se permet de chasser des
espèces qui sont en danger au niveau
mondial et qui chasse le plus longtemps
dans l'année en allemagne il ya trois
cent mille chasseurs et ils le chassent
sept cent mille 100 villes et en france
si on a un million ils ont chasse 600 à
700 milles cherchez l'erreur donc le
texte qui est soumis pourquoi on nous on
va nous tuer les renards on en tue pas
assez des renards on va nous tuer les
renards début juin on va libéraliser la
chasse au renard
si c'était qu'un poème de sangliers
expliquez moi pourquoi on y glisse avec
le renard et le chevreuil le fait de
laisser les renard qui est laid ni au
mois de juin pour nourrir les jeunes
détruire des espèces qui sont
potentiellement en danger
ça ça vous dérange pas manifestement
vous êtes beaucoup plus agacés par le
chasseur que par la disparition des
oiseaux vous ne pensez seuls
responsables de la diminution du nombre
des espèces
seuls deux responsables de la
disparition de l'avifaune de plaine
apparemment un personne ne va rien dire
d'autres lobbys parce qu'on est quand
même plus petit et plus facile à
attaquer alors là la mauvaise foi ça se
pose là bon je suis ravi qu en france on
est beaucoup d'espèces à chasser ça
diminue la pression espèce par espèce et
c'est la fin de cette émission prochain
point sur l'actualité demain matin 7
heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous sur rt
france
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ceux qui six interdit d'interdire